This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus. And he realizes, or rather everybody else realizes, that there is a vast continent out there. And it is, of course, the Americas. So Anthropic knows the importance of questions. And it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution
本期节目由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。历史上的重大飞跃往往始于人们不愿触及的难题。在15世纪末，就有一个经典的例子。当时一个特别棘手的难题是：大西洋以西究竟有什么？众所周知，找到这个答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布。他意识到，或者说大家最终都意识到，那里有一片广阔的大陆。当然，那就是美洲。Anthropic深知提问的重要性，这也是Anthropic创立时最核心的一个难题：我们如何确保人工智能革命
really goes well for ordinary people? So they asked over 100,000 people and what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clodd.aI slash rest is history. Keep thinking. Mr. President, my company formed me of the explosion on our rig. On October 2nd.
真正造福普通大众？因此，他们询问了超过10万人的意见，得到的反馈不仅有恐惧，还有希望。人们想知道，癌症终有一天会被治愈吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。请访问clodd.aI slash rest is history提出你的问题。保持思考。总统先生，我的公司通知我，我们的钻井平台发生了爆炸。在10月2日。
Causing massive water displacement and triggering a tsunami. They all heap to blame on me. Tom Cruise is. Digger got us into this mess. And Digger's gonna dig us up. From the director of Birdman and the Revenant. What would happen if I stop doing?
导致了大规模的水体位移并引发了海啸。他们都把责任推到我身上。汤姆·克鲁斯饰演的迪格让我们陷入了这场混乱。而迪格会把我们挖出来。来自《鸟人》和《荒野猎人》导演的作品。如果我停止工作会发生什么？
You starve. You freeze to death. That's what? With great power. Comes great deniability. I'm not the earth, Danny. Digger. See the trailer online. Only appears October 2nd.
你会饿死。你会冻死。那又怎样？能力越大，否认的责任就越大。我不是地球，丹尼。迪格。在线观看预告片。10月2日仅限上映。
We are now, therefore, got to that black precipitous abyss, where all things have long been tending, where, having now arrived on the giddy verge, they hurled down in confused ruin, headlong pell-mell, down, down, till sonculottism have consummated itself. And in this wondrous French revolution, as in a doomsday, a world have been rapidly, if not born again, yet destroyed and engulfed. Terror has long been terrible, but to the actors themselves, it has now become manifest that their appointed course is one of terror, and they say, be it so,
因此，我们现在来到了那个黑暗险峻的深渊，万物早已趋向于此。如今，当他们来到这令人眩晕的边缘，便一头栽进混乱的废墟中，头朝下，乱作一团，不断下坠，直到无套裤汉主义彻底完成。在这场奇妙的法国大革命中，就像世界末日一样，一个世界即便没有重生，也已被迅速摧毁并吞噬。恐怖统治早已令人恐惧，但对于当事人来说，现在已经显而易见，他们所选定的道路就是恐怖，他们说，就这样吧，
that terror so la terror be the order of the day. Let terror be the order of the day. So what a dramatic moment, a key point in the sense. story of the French Revolution, the start of the terror. So this passage, which describes this great turning point, the dawning of the reign of terror, comes from the single most influential history of the French Revolution that has ever been written in our native tongue. And the man who wrote it was one of the absolute intellectual titans of Victorian Britain. He was the Scottish historian and philosopher Thomas Carlyle. Now, some of you might have found that reading a little bit
让恐怖，即“la terreur”，成为当天的秩序。让恐怖成为当天的秩序。这是一个多么戏剧性的时刻，是法国大革命故事中的一个关键点，恐怖统治的开始。这段描述了这一伟大转折点、恐怖统治黎明的文字，出自有史以来用我们母语写成的最具影响力的法国大革命史。作者是维多利亚时代英国绝对的知识泰斗之一，苏格兰历史学家兼哲学家托马斯·卡莱尔。现在，你们中有些人可能觉得这段朗读有点
theatrical, but of course that was Carlisle's style. Some people might even say a melodramatic style, and I think they'd be right. So he's writing often the present tense, so it gives you this incredibly vivid, palpable sense of immediacy. He puts you right in the heart of the revolution. And as you can tell from that passage, Tom, Carlisle sees the revolution. as the equivalent of the flood or the apocalypse in the book of Revelation, this titanic biblical reckoning between the forces of radicalism and violence and the forces of the established order. And the terror, this point in our story, 1793, 1794, is the absolute climax. Yes, so Carlisleck casts it as this
戏剧化，但当然，这就是卡莱尔的风格。有些人甚至会说这是一种夸张的风格，我想他们是对的。他经常用现在时写作，这让你有一种极其生动、真切的临场感。他把你直接带到了革命的核心。正如你从那段文字中听出的，汤姆，卡莱尔将革命视为《启示录》中的洪水或末日，这是激进暴力力量与既定秩序力量之间一场泰坦尼克式的圣经式清算。而恐怖，也就是我们故事中的这个节点，1793年到1794年，是绝对的高潮。是的，卡莱尔将其描绘成这种
kind of immense, unstoppable conflagration consumes all in its path and even its own profits. So Saturn devouring its own children. We talked about that in our first episode. And also, Dominic, in our first episode, we talked about how for the British and perhaps for the Anglophone world more generally, the terror is really what the revolution is all about. And it's not a coincidence that Carlisle was a massive. massive influence on Charles Dickens, who said that he'd read it 500 times, Carlisle's book
一种巨大的、不可阻挡的烈火，吞噬了路径上的一切，甚至包括它自己的先知。就像萨图尔努斯吞噬自己的孩子。我们在第一集中谈到过这一点。而且，多米尼克，在第一集中，我们还谈到对于英国人，或许对于更广泛的英语世界来说，恐怖确实就是革命的全部意义所在。卡莱尔对查尔斯·狄更斯产生了巨大的、巨大的影响，这绝非巧合，狄更斯说他读过500遍卡莱尔的
on the French Revolution. And so it's his principal source for Tale of Two Cities, which is, I mean, amazing, the best-selling novel in English. So that is the novel that's imprinted this idea of the revolution as being equivalent to terror, I think, in the kind of the British imagination. And this is where our sense of it as streams of blood, tumbrills, all of that that we were talking about yesterday comes from. And I would say that in Britain, far more than any other European country, the terror is actually seen almost as synonymous with the French Revolution itself.
《法国大革命》。所以这是他创作《双城记》的主要来源，我的意思是，这太惊人了，这是英语世界最畅销的小说。正是这部小说将革命等同于恐怖的观念深深印刻在了英国人的想象中。我们昨天谈到的血流成河、囚车等等，都是从这里来的。我想说，在英国，远比在其他任何欧洲国家，恐怖实际上几乎被视为法国大革命本身的同义词。
So actually, in a lot of European countries, there is an emphasis on the kind of the more progressive elements of the revolution. The metric system. Not just the metric system, but the language of rights and that kind of thing. But by the British, it's just mad people chopping each other's heads off. And do you know the person who magnificently, magnificently sum this up? I do. I know what you're going to say. So this is an interview that Madame Thatcher gave in 1989 to Le Monde.
事实上，在许多欧洲国家，人们更强调革命中比较进步的元素。公制系统。不仅仅是公制系统，还有权利的语言等等。但在英国人看来，这只是一群疯子在互相砍头。你知道是谁精彩地、极其精彩地总结了这一点吗？我知道。我知道你要说什么。这是撒切尔夫人在1989年接受《世界报》采访时说的话。
And 1989, of course, the bicentennial of Bastille of Bastille Day. of the start of the French Revolution. And it was part of a series of interviews with leaders from the G7 who were attending a summit in Paris. And all the other six leaders were incredibly respectful of the revolution
1989年，当然是巴士底狱日，也就是法国大革命开始两百周年。这是她与参加巴黎峰会的七国集团领导人系列访谈的一部分。其他六位领导人都对革命表现得极其尊重，
and everything that had given humanity through all this language of rights and stuff. Mrs. Thatcher absolutely uncompromising refusal to be diplomatic. And she said that the revolution was a terrible thing. Up to the final death of Rob's Piers, oh, it was an age of terror.
以及它通过所有这些权利语言等赋予人类的一切。撒切尔夫人绝对不妥协，拒绝外交辞令。她说革命是一件可怕的事情。直到罗伯斯庇尔最终死亡，哦，那是一个恐怖的时代。
It was an age of terror. We did ours much more quietly. She's not entirely wrong, to be fair. Well, I mean, I suppose we did chop off the head of a king, but I think she's talking about the glorious revolution, and there was a lack of guillotining in that. And so you said that in this series, we're going to be looking at the reality behind the myth.
那是一个恐怖的时代。我们做得安静得多。公平地说，她并不完全错误。嗯，我的意思是，我想我们确实砍掉了一位国王的头，但我认为她指的是光荣革命，那次革命中缺乏断头台。所以你说过，在这个系列中，我们将审视神话背后的现实。
And for British listeners, the myth, is this notion of the notion of, revolution being all about terror. And so listeners may be thinking this idea of terror, is this just a kind of francophobic, British, something that they've imagined, something perhaps made up by Carlisle, one of his rhetorical flourishes, one of his melodramatic flourishes. But actually, it's not at all. Because the idea of terror being the order of the day, it originates with the revolutionaries themselves, doesn't it? Completely it does.
对于英国听众来说，这个神话就是革命完全是关于恐怖的观念。所以听众可能会想，这种恐怖的概念，这只是一种恐法症、英国人的某种想象，或者是卡莱尔编造出来的，是他修辞上的华丽辞藻之一，是他夸张的修辞手法之一吗？但实际上，根本不是这样。因为“恐怖是当天的秩序”这一理念，起源于革命者自己，不是吗？完全是这样。
They never use the phrase. They don't call themselves terrorists, as some historians later do, nor do they ever use the expression of the reign of terror, as lots of historians do, and it's very common in the popular imagination. But the word terror, and terror as a positive political policy, as a strategy, as a deliberate choice, is there from 1793, and arguably even earlier, is implicit in a lot of what they're saying, isn't it?
他们从未使用过这个词组。他们不称自己为恐怖分子，正如一些后来的历史学家所做的那样，他们也从未使用过“恐怖统治”这个表达，尽管很多历史学家都这么用，而且这在公众想象中非常普遍。但是“恐怖”这个词，以及作为一种积极的政治政策、一种策略、一种深思熟虑的选择的恐怖，从1793年甚至更早的时候就存在了，在他们所说的很多话中都是隐含的，不是吗？
So that phrase that Carlisle quotes, let terror be the order of the day, he is quoting a slogan that was publicly pronounced by a man called Bertrand Barre, who was one of the 12 men who sat on the Committee of Public Safety, which we talked about yesterday, this kind of proto-dictatorial institution that had been set up on the 6th of April 1793. and it was never enshrined as a kind of official policy. It was never an official motion of the National Convention, which in effect was the government of Revolutionary France, but it didn't need to be adopted as an official policy. And Barrier proclaimed it on the 5th of September 1793, so some two months after the murder of Marat, which we were talking about in the previous episode.
所以卡莱尔引用的那句“让恐怖成为当天的秩序”，他引用的是一个叫贝特朗·巴雷尔的人公开宣称的口号，他是坐在救国委员会里的12个人之一，我们昨天谈到过，这是在1793年4月6日建立的一种准独裁机构。它从未被确立为一种官方政策。它从未成为国民公会的官方动议，而国民公会实际上就是革命法国的政府，但它不需要被采纳为官方政策。巴雷尔在1793年9月5日宣布了这一点，也就是在我们上一集谈到的马拉被谋杀大约两个月后。
And Barrier was offering this policy of terror as a way of dealing with all the multiple interlocking crises that we heard about in that first episode. So war, counter-revolution, civil war, economic collapse, the collapse of the revolutionaries themselves into kind of bloodthirsty faction fighting. And Baraire's goal in saying let terror be the order of the day was to institutionalize repression against the perceived enemies of the revolution and thereby to save it. And what this meant in practice was to reframe what had hitherto been ad hoc violence, violence that kind of emerged from the streets.
巴雷尔提出这种恐怖政策，是为了应对我们在第一集中听到的所有多重交织的危机。战争、反革命、内战、经济崩溃、革命者自身陷入嗜血的派系斗争。巴雷尔说“让恐怖成为当天的秩序”，其目标是将针对革命敌人的镇压制度化，从而拯救革命。在实践中，这意味着将迄今为止临时的暴力，即那种从街头涌现的暴力，重新定义为
Yeah, the September massacres in the prisons, for example. Chaotic, anarchic. All of that. And to reframe it as a kind of formal state policy. But just to reiterate, even this is, it's still fundamentally an attempt at crisis management. It's an emergency measure. It's a response to the crisis that is overwhelming the revolution. It strikes me that there's two different schools of thought here, two different kinds of terror. So what you're describing as the crisis management is terror as defensive.
是的，比如监狱里的九月大屠杀。混乱的、无政府状态的。所有这些。并将其重新定义为一种正式的国家政策。但重申一下，即使是这样，它本质上仍然是一种危机管理的尝试。这是一种紧急措施。这是对压倒革命的危机的回应。我感觉这里有两种不同的思想流派，两种不同类型的恐怖。所以你所描述的危机管理是防御性的恐怖。
It's terror as in, you know, this is a bulwark against our enemies. But there is another way of thinking about the terror, isn't there? which is much more almost terror as a positive force, terror on the offensive, terror as remodeling society or giving you a kind of a, I suppose, a philosophy of government. And this brings us to the person at the heart of the story. I mean, you might say literally a blood bath that the blood washes away the taints of monarchy and aristocracy and superstition and that you have to have the blood bath so that something pure and better can emerge from it. And this is quite a minority position in the beginning of 1793, but it will become increasingly influential. And the person who is most associated with it, probably the most famous or maybe notorious figure in the whole French Revolution, was the one revolutionary that was named checked by Mrs. Thatcher in that interview with Le Monde. and who on the 5th of September when Barré proclaimed Terra the Order of the Day was actually the president of the convention, and that is Maximilien Robespierre.
它是恐怖，你知道，这是抵御我们敌人的堡垒。但还有另一种思考恐怖的方式，不是吗？这几乎更像是作为一种积极力量的恐怖，进攻性的恐怖，作为重塑社会或赋予你一种，我想，政府哲学的恐怖。这把我们带到了故事的核心人物。我的意思是，你甚至可以说这实际上是一场血浴，鲜血洗去了君主制、贵族制和迷信的污点，你必须进行这场血浴，这样纯洁和美好的东西才能从中产生。这在1793年初是一个相当少数的立场，但它将变得越来越有影响力。而与此联系最紧密的人，可能是整个法国大革命中最著名，或者说臭名昭著的人物，就是撒切尔夫人在接受《世界报》采访时点名提到的那位革命者。而且在9月5日巴雷尔宣布恐怖成为当天的秩序时，他实际上是国民公会的主席，那就是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。
So he is, people can probably have a sense of what he looks like. He is in 1793, 35 years old. He is short. He is slender. He is pale. In his appearance, he's compared by one contemporary to a cat. that at some time he looks like a kind of domestic tabby at other times like a fierce tiger. In our previous series about the French Revolution, Rob Spears being kind of threaded through it.
所以，人们可能对他的长相有个概念。在1793年，他35岁。他个子不高。他身材苗条。他脸色苍白。在外观上，一位同时代的人将他比作一只猫。有时他看起来像一只家养的虎斑猫，有时又像一只凶猛的老虎。在我们之前关于法国大革命的系列节目中，罗伯斯庇尔一直贯穿其中。
You know, he's bobbed up from time to time and then gone away again. And he's not really at that point the undisputed star of the revolution. But this is the moment, isn't it? The sort of second half of 1793, when he finds himself cast or casts himself as the absolute central figure in the drama. And he becomes identified with the whole policy of terror. He embodies it. He personifies it, doesn't he? Perceived as its architect, perhaps not always fairly, I would say, actually. But he certainly articulates it more fluently and confidently than anybody else. Yeah, so he becomes the face of the terror, both when it is being prosecuted and in the wake of it.
你知道，他时不时地出现，然后又消失了。在那时，他并不是革命中无可争议的明星。但这就是那个时刻，不是吗？1793年的下半年，他发现自己被塑造成，或者说他自己将自己塑造成了这场戏剧中绝对的核心人物。他与整个恐怖政策联系在了一起。他体现了它。他代表了它，不是吗？被视为它的建筑师，虽然我认为并不总是公平的。但他确实比任何人都更流利、更自信地阐述了它。是的，所以他成为了恐怖的代言人，无论是在它被执行时，还是在它之后。
And, I mean, on the one hand, I mean, fewer people die in the terror than are killed in the British Army on the first day of the song. I mean, that is one way of looking at it. On the other hand, I mean, a lot of people are killed in the terror. So something like 17,000 people across the whole of France get to be executed as traitors and enemies of the revolution. And then you were talking yesterday about the von deray. I mean, a huge scale of slaughter there. that some French historians compare it to genocide. And certainly in Paris, the center of the revolution, there is a kind of hideous melodrama to the displays of executions that are going on.
而且，一方面，在恐怖统治中死亡的人数比索姆河战役第一天在英国军队中阵亡的人数还要少。我的意思是，这是一种看待它的方式。另一方面，我的意思是，在恐怖统治中确实有很多人被杀。所以整个法国大约有17,000人被作为叛徒和革命的敌人处决。然后你昨天谈到了旺代。我的意思是，那里有大规模的屠杀。一些法国历史学家将其比作种族灭绝。当然，在革命中心巴黎，正在进行的处决展示有一种极其丑陋的戏剧性。
I mean, this is why the guillotining is so memorable. The guillotine was designed to be merciful, to be an enlightened way of killing people. But the speed with which the blade drops onto the neck results in great geysers of blood welling out. So it is a really spectacular, terrifying sight. And so much blood ends up flowing over the course of the terror into the water supply that it becomes poisoned. And they have to move the guillotine because the blood is getting into the water system. And I think to his enemies, Robespierre comes to seem the embodiment of everything that is making this happen,
我的意思是，这就是为什么断头台如此令人难忘。断头台被设计成仁慈的，是一种开明的杀人方式。但刀片落到脖子上的速度导致了巨大的血柱喷涌而出。所以这是一个非常壮观、可怕的景象。在恐怖统治期间，有太多的血流入供水系统，以至于水被污染了。他们不得不移动断头台，因为血进入了供水系统。我想在他的敌人看来，罗伯斯庇尔似乎成了导致这一切发生的一切的化身，
a kind of a monster who is threatening to turn the whole of France into a cemetery. And there is a famous cartoon which was published towards the end of the terror, which illustrates this. And it shows, Robespierre, to quote the caption, guillotining the executioner after having had all the French guillotined. So this sense of the terror as something that will end up consuming the entire country. And you mentioned the word terrorist. So it's originally coined in French in 1794 after the terror has formerly been brought to an end to describe a class of person who had never before needed to be described. So this is the birth of our notion of terrorism as a positive because terrorists obviously think that they are doing often God's work or the work of the people or whatever. They do indeed.
一个威胁要把整个法国变成墓地的怪物。有一幅著名的漫画在恐怖统治末期出版，说明了这一点。它展示了罗伯斯庇尔，引用标题的话，在让所有法国人被送上断头台后，又将刽子手送上了断头台。所以这种将恐怖视为最终会吞噬整个国家的观念。你提到了“恐怖分子”这个词。所以它最初是在1794年恐怖统治正式结束后在法语中创造出来的，用来描述一种以前从未需要被描述的人。所以这就是我们对恐怖主义作为一种积极事物的概念的诞生，因为恐怖分子显然认为他们经常是在做上帝的工作，或者人民的工作，等等。他们确实是这样。
But you know you were talking about Rob Spierre, this idea that people have of Rob Spier is this monster hungry for blood. I mean, it's so common. It's common in political rhetoric. And Rob Spier's bloodlust, his desire to sacrifice human life in pursuit of a better world has become an absolute staple of conservative political thoughts, hasn't it really? I mean, he's a sort of monster haunting the conservative imagination. And yet the funny thing about Rob Spier is when you look at him in so many ways, you know, he is not Stalin or he's not. Pull pot or something. So you give the example, don't you, in your notes? A really obvious point, Robespierre is personally extremely squeamish. And this will astound people, this man who is famous for guillotining all these thousands of people. He, all his life, had consistently opposed capital punishment. Completely. We did an episode on the introduction of the guillotine and how Robespier stood up. You know, right the way through all the meetings that were structuring the revolution from 1789 onwards, opposing the death penalty. And he had a profound personal horror of violence.
但你知道你刚才谈到罗伯斯庇尔，人们对罗伯斯庇尔是嗜血怪物的这种想法。我的意思是，这太普遍了。这在政治修辞中很常见。罗伯斯庇尔的嗜血，他为了追求一个更美好的世界而牺牲人类生命的欲望，已经成为保守派政治思想的绝对主食了，不是吗？我的意思是，他是困扰保守派想象力的一种怪物。然而，关于罗伯斯庇尔有趣的事情是，当你从很多方面看他时，你知道，他不是斯大林，也不是波尔布特之类的人。所以你在笔记中举了例子，不是吗？一个非常明显的点，罗伯斯庇尔个人极其敏感。这会让人们感到震惊，这个以将成千上万的人送上断头台而闻名的人，他一生都始终反对死刑。完全反对。我们做过一期关于断头台引入的节目，以及罗伯斯庇尔是如何站出来的。你知道，从1789年开始，贯穿所有构建革命的会议，他一直反对死刑。而且他对暴力有一种深刻的个人恐惧。
For instance, he had opposed the war against Austria and Prussia that the Girondin had pushed. He was very against it. Even though, ultimately, he is, you know, he's part of the institution that is responsible for sending people to the guillotine. He never goes and watch his executions himself. He hasn't got the stomach for it. And even during the terror itself, he does disapprove of a lot of the more indiscriminate atrocities that are being perpetrated out in the provinces.
例如，他反对吉伦特派推动的对奥地利和普鲁士的战争。他非常反对。尽管最终，你知道，他是负责将人们送上断头台的机构的一部分。他从不亲自去看处决。他没有那个胆量。即使在恐怖统治期间，他也确实不赞成在各省发生的一些更不分青红皂白的暴行。
We talked yesterday about Mara, how the stress of being in the eye of the political storm brought him out in kind of boils and all kinds of skin complaints. I think Robespierre, likewise, finds the process of administering the terror very stressful, which I'm sure won't be much consolation to those their victims. But it is notable that he seems to have retired to his bed in a state of kind of nervous collapse throughout the months of the terror. So he's, as you say, he's absolutely
我们昨天谈到了马拉，谈到处于政治风暴中心带来的压力是如何让他长出疖子和各种皮肤病的。我想罗伯斯庇尔同样觉得管理恐怖的过程压力很大，我相信这对那些受害者来说不会是什么安慰。但值得注意的是，在恐怖统治的几个月里，他似乎一直处于一种神经崩溃的状态，退缩到了床上。所以，正如你所说，他绝对
not Stalin. He's not cavalier about this. He feels the burden of it, I think, very personally. And also his political opinions, I mean, they are. very liberal Democrat. They're very inoffensive. They are exactly the kind of thing that today constitutes the political mainstream for parties in pretty much every Western democracy, I would say. We mentioned how Robespierre opposes the death penalty. He also is a keen supporter of freedom of the press. He's worked this throughout his life. He's in favor of universal male suffrage, not female suffrage, although he is incredibly popular with revolutionary women, as we will see. He supports progressive taxation to support universal education. He supports the idea
不是斯大林。他对此并不漫不经心。我认为他非常个人化地感受到了它的负担。而且他的政治观点，我的意思是，它们是非常自由民主的。它们非常无害。它们正是今天构成几乎每个西方民主国家政党政治主流的东西，我想说。我们提到罗伯斯庇尔反对死刑。他也是新闻自由的坚定支持者。他一生都在为此努力。他赞成普遍的男性选举权，而不是女性选举权，尽管正如我们将看到的，他在革命女性中非常受欢迎。他支持累进税以支持全民教育。他支持
of human rights. He's a firm believer in them. And he's an abolitionist. He wants to see slavery go. So these are all pretty politically impeccable positions from the perspective of today. Woke's garden reading Snowflake, who knew? A further thing. that is strange about him. You're talking yesterday about how Mara dresses in a way that makes him seem the embodiment of the revolution. He dresses as a child of the street and how by 1793 this is something that most revolutionaries are doing. This is not Robespier's vibe at all. Robespier's vibe does not remotely seem that of a revolutionary itching to drown the Anseigne regime in blood. So Timothy Tackett in his book on The Terror, which we've been quoting a lot in this series, he quotes one of Robespierre's colleagues in 1793, who is very into this notion of kind of repudiating aristocratic fashion. And this guy says, we now all look like beggars, boots and threadbare clothing, such as our stylish costume. These are the clothes that people in the convention are wearing almost as a kind of uniform. But Rovst Pierre, I mean, for him, it might as well be Versailles.
人权的理念。他是这些理念的坚定信徒。而且他是一位废奴主义者。他希望看到奴隶制的终结。所以从今天的角度来看，这些都是政治上无可挑剔的立场。觉醒派的雪花，谁知道呢？还有一件事。关于他很奇怪。你昨天谈到马拉的穿着方式让他看起来像是革命的化身。他穿着街头孩子的衣服，到1793年，这是大多数革命者都在做的事情。这根本不是罗伯斯庇尔的风格。罗伯斯庇尔的风格一点也不像一个渴望将旧制度淹没在血泊中的革命者。所以蒂莫西·塔克特在他关于《恐怖》的书中，我们在这个系列中引用了很多，他引用了罗伯斯庇尔1793年的一位同事的话，他非常热衷于这种否定贵族时尚的观念。这家伙说，我们现在看起来都像乞丐，靴子和破旧的衣服，这就是我们的时髦装束。这些是国民公会里的人几乎作为一种制服穿的衣服。但罗伯斯庇尔，我的意思是，对他来说，这和凡尔赛宫没什么两样。
1781 or something. So he loves a powdered wig. He loves an embroidered waistcoat. He loves a weight coat. Robsbyer loves silk stockings. He loves a handsome blue coat. And the thing about the stockings is interesting because, of course, the collot are the britches that the aristocracy used to wear at Versailles to complement the stockings.
1781年什么的。所以他喜欢戴粉末假发。他喜欢绣花背心。他喜欢礼服大衣。罗伯斯庇尔喜欢丝绸长袜。他喜欢一件漂亮的外套。关于长袜的事情很有趣，因为当然，“无套裤汉”就是贵族过去在凡尔赛宫穿的用来搭配长袜的马裤。
And so the song culot is people who wear trousers, people who can't afford this style. And as early as 1791, Robespierre had been described by a fellow revolutionary as the general of the son culot. But Robespierre himself, despite being the general of the sonculot, he's still wearing collot. He has them. He's wearing his pantaloons. And so it is striking that the man who, more than anyone else, is associated with sweeping away the old order should affect the fashions of that very order. Yeah, because he's so prim. He's so meticulous. He's so dapper.
所以“无套裤汉”就是穿长裤的人，买不起这种款式的人。早在1791年，罗伯斯庇尔就被一位革命同僚描述为“无套裤汉的将军”。但罗伯斯庇尔本人，尽管是无套裤汉的将军，他仍然穿着马裤。他有它们。他穿着他的长裤。所以令人震惊的是，这个比任何人都更与扫除旧秩序联系在一起的人，竟然会模仿那个秩序的时尚。是的，因为他太拘谨了。他太一丝不苟了。他太整洁了。
Fastidious. Now, what's going on there? How do you reconcile those two things? I mean, it's fascinating from the point of view of personal psychology. But I think it also matters because looking at Robespier's character and background helps us as well maybe to get a handle on what's going on in the terror because Robespierre is so influential on it. And so before we carry the story on from the death of Marat or the turbulent events that we'll be following that, let's just have a quick look at Robespier's backstory because we haven't given it yet in the course of our various series on the French Revolution. Maybe see what clues we can find there.
挑剔。现在，那里发生了什么？你如何调和这两件事？我的意思是，从个人心理学的角度来看，这很迷人。但我认为这也很重要，因为审视罗伯斯庇尔的性格和背景也有助于我们也许能掌握恐怖统治中正在发生的事情，因为罗伯斯庇尔对它的影响太大了。所以，在我们从马拉之死或我们将要跟随的动荡事件中继续讲述故事之前，让我们快速看一下罗伯斯庇尔的背景故事，因为我们在关于法国大革命的各个系列中还没有讲过。也许看看我们能在那里找到什么线索。
Love a clue. Brilliant. So Robespierre was born on 6th of May 1758 in Arras, which is a town on France's borders with Holland. And it's very prosperous, it's very pious, and it's unbelievably boring. And Rodfier's early life is marked by kind of repeated tragedies and petty humiliations. And reading about them kind of remind me of 19th century novels that always feature these kind of things, Madame Bovary or something like that, where they're a small scale tragedies, but obviously incredibly personally felt if you were the person experiencing them. And do you remember how we were talking in the Mara episode about how Robert Danton has this thing about, so many of the revolutionaries have a sense of disappointment, frustration, personal, professional in their early lives that gives them a sense of resentment and unfinished business? And I wonder if that's the case with Robert Spying.
喜欢线索。太棒了。所以罗伯斯庇尔于1758年5月6日出生在阿拉斯，这是一个位于法国与荷兰边境的城镇。它非常繁荣，非常虔诚，而且令人难以置信的无聊。罗伯斯庇尔的早年生活以各种反复的悲剧和琐碎的羞辱为标志。读到这些，让我想起了总是以这些事情为特色的19世纪小说，《包法利夫人》之类的，它们是小规模的悲剧，但如果你是经历它们的人，显然会感到非常深刻。你还记得我们在马拉那一集中谈到罗伯·丹东有这种感觉吗？所以很多革命者在早年生活中都有某种失望、挫折感，无论是个人还是职业上的，这给了他们一种怨恨和未竟事业的感觉？我想知道罗伯斯庇尔是否也是这样。
I mean, he definitely has a, there's something gnawing at him, isn't there? Yeah, so in that context, I mean, let's look at his parents. So his father was a lawyer who was very unstable. and very downwardly mobile. And he had got Roch-Pierre's mother, who was the unmarried daughter of a brewer,
我的意思是，他肯定有一种，有什么东西在啃噬他，不是吗？是的，在这种背景下，我的意思是，让我们看看他的父母。所以他的父亲是一名律师，非常不稳定。
so considerably lower class to a lawyer. He got her pregnant. So it was a shotgun wedding, and Maximilian was born four months after his parents' wedding. And his parents go on to have three more children,
而且非常向下流动。他让罗伯斯庇尔的母亲怀孕了，她是酿酒商未婚的女儿，
so a brother for Maximilian, Augustin, and two sisters, Charlotte and Henriette. And then father is an increasingly absent presence. His downward spiral continues. Their mother is a continuous presence and all her children clearly adored her. And so that means that when in 1764, when Maximilion was only six, she dies, the impact is felt, I think, by all four children as a completely crushing blow. And Maximilien in particular was devastated. And throughout his adult life, whenever his mother was
所以阶级比律师低得多。他让她怀孕了。所以这是一场奉子成婚，马克西米连是在他父母结婚四个月后出生的。他的父母后来又有了三个孩子，
mentioned, tears would come to his eyes. He would completely tear up. Their father basically by now has vanished. He is not the kind of man who is prepared to shoulder the burden of looking after four motherless children. He vanishes from the scene. And so the children end up being divided up between kind of various relatives. So the two girls go to live with their paternal aunts and the two boys, Maximilienne and Augustin, go to live with their paternal grandparents who are the brewers. Peter McPhee, in his biography, of Rovierre, brilliant biography,
所以马克西米连有一个弟弟奥古斯丁，还有两个妹妹夏洛特和亨丽埃特。然后父亲的存在感越来越弱。他的螺旋式下降仍在继续。他们的母亲是一个持续的存在，所有的孩子显然都崇拜她。所以这意味着当1764年，马克西米连只有六岁时，她去世了，我认为这对所有四个孩子来说都是一个彻底的毁灭性打击。马克西米连尤其感到悲痛。在他成年后的生活中，每当提到他的母亲，
writes that although born into a long line of lawyers and officials, Maximilien was now to be brought up in a milieu of manual work, with the sounds of carts and workers shouting in the local Picard dialect in the Rue-Rondville. So, on the one hand, perhaps this is giving him a sense of identification, with the workers, people who are working with their hands. On the other hand, you can understand why he would perhaps have wanted to hold on to the outward signs of respectability. Hence the clothes.
他的眼里就会涌出泪水。他会完全泪流满面。他们的父亲基本上现在已经消失了。他不是那种准备承担照顾四个丧母孩子重担的人。他从现场消失了。所以孩子们最终被分给了各种亲戚。两个女孩去和她们的父系姑姑住在一起，两个男孩，马克西米连和奥古斯丁，去和他们的父系祖父母住在一起，也就是那些酿酒商。彼得·麦克菲在他那本关于罗伯斯庇尔的精彩传记中，
So I think there is a kind of intriguing tension there. And definitely it generates a sense of insecurity in him, as also does the fact that the same year that his mother dies, so when he's six, he gets smallpox and it leaves his face kind of pot marked. So he's a little bit marginal, maybe. It feels a bit out of an outsider It doesn't quite fit You know, he doesn't fit with the Brewers Yeah But equally the fact that he's been brought up by brewers
写道，尽管出生于律师和官员世家，马克西米连现在却要在体力劳动的环境中长大，周围是皮卡第方言的马车声和工人的叫喊声。所以，一方面，这也许给了他一种认同感，与工人、用双手工作的人的认同感。另一方面，你可以理解为什么他可能想要保持体面的外在标志。因此才有了那些衣服。
Means he doesn't quite fit with the middle class people That he aspires to join And the other thing, of course, he's not a funster, is he? Well, I think unsurprisingly When you think of that, you know, all the kind of tragedies he's been through, he's not a funster. He grows up a very earnest, anxious,
所以我认为那里有一种耐人寻味的张力。而且它肯定在他心中产生了一种不安全感，就像他母亲去世的那一年，也就是他六岁时，他得了天花，这让他的脸变得坑坑洼洼。所以他有点边缘化，也许。他感觉自己有点像个局外人。他不太合群。你知道，他不适合酿酒商。是的。但同样，他是由酿酒商抚养长大的事实
reserved little boy And he's definitely not one of life's party animals. So his sister Charlotte, years later writing about his childhood, recalled that he very rarely played games and that when he was involved in the games, his role was the chief thing that he was into was clarifying and insisting on the rules. Oh, no, the worst kind of child. So, again, whether there is a clue there as to the role that he will adopt for himself in due course. He's also, and I like this about him.
意味着他不太适合他渴望加入的中产阶级。当然，还有一件事，他不是个有趣的人，不是吗？嗯，我想不出所料，当你想到那个，你知道，他经历过的所有悲剧，他不是个有趣的人。他长大后是一个非常认真、焦虑、
He's a great fan of the pigeon. So like Gordon Carrera and myself. Pigeons and sparrows. And he keeps them and feeds them and kind of looks after them. And his sisters were always begging him to be allowed to look after these pigeons. And Maximilien was very reluctant because he didn't trust them. And finally he gives in and the girls inevitably leave Rojpheus' favorite pigeon outside in the garden. There's a storm and the pigeon dies.
内向的小男孩。他绝对不是那种生活中的派对动物。所以他的妹妹夏洛特多年后在写他的童年时回忆说，他很少玩游戏，当他参与游戏时，他的角色是主要的事情，他热衷于澄清和坚持规则。哦，不，最糟糕的那种孩子。所以，同样，这是否暗示了他将来会为自己采取的角色。他也是，我喜欢他这一点。
And Charlotte recalled how, at the news of this, death, the tears of Maximilien flowed. So all these tears, this is the age of sentiment. Yeah, death of a pigeon. Robespierre is totally buying into that kind of sensibility. Why would the pigeon die in a storm? That's what baffles me. Pigeons don't generally die in storms. Probably struck by lightning, I imagine. Struck by lightning? I'm offering a thesis, I don't know. I think history is silent on that. So he's potmarked, he's lost his mother. He's very earnest. He doesn't play games.
他是一个鸽子迷。就像戈登·卡雷拉和我一样。鸽子和麻雀。他养着它们，喂它们，照顾它们。他的妹妹们总是求他允许她们照顾这些鸽子。马克西米连非常不情愿，因为他不信任她们。最后他屈服了，女孩们不可避免地把罗伯斯庇尔最喜欢的鸽子留在了花园里。有一场暴风雨，鸽子死了。
He's lost his pigeons. You might think things are looking terrible for him. But actually, it's okay because he is brilliantly intelligent. He turns out to be an absolutely superb student. And he wins a scholarship to an elite Jesuit foundation. It's not actually being run by the Jesuits at this point because they've been expelled from France, but it still maintains that Jesuit ethos of emphasizing education. And this is a school called the Collège Louis Le Grand.
夏洛特回忆说，听到这个死讯时，马克西米连的泪水流了下来。所以所有的这些泪水，这是感伤的时代。是的，鸽子的死。罗伯斯庇尔完全接受了那种情感。为什么鸽子会在暴风雨中死去？这让我感到困惑。鸽子通常不会死在暴风雨中。我想可能是被闪电击中了。被闪电击中？我只是提出一个假设，我不知道。我认为历史对此保持沉默。所以他满脸麻子，他失去了母亲。他非常认真。他不玩游戏。
in Paris and previous alumni of this school had included Molière and Voltaire and also intriguing the Marquis de Sard so he'd been there too and I looked this up and the list of alumni who followed in Rob Spears' weight is amazing so Victor Hugo Sartre Rolombardt Jacques Chirac. Jack Chirac, friend of the show. A man who loves a quick shower. Yeah, Mr. Five Minutes or whatever he was called. I think it's three minutes, wasn't it? Shower included, remember? Jacques Derrida.
他失去了他的鸽子。你可能认为情况对他来说看起来很糟糕。但实际上，没关系，因为他非常聪明。他证明是一个绝对出色的学生。他赢得了一份精英耶稣会基金会的奖学金。它此时实际上并不是由耶稣会士运营的，因为他们已经被驱逐出法国，但它仍然保持着耶稣会强调教育的精神。这是一所名为路易大帝中学的学校，
Okay. Thomas Pinkety. So, I mean, an absolute roll call of famous French writers and intellectuals. Wow. And Jacques Chirac. Very good. And when he's at the... It's when he's at the school that this incredibly famous mythologized moment happens, which
位于巴黎，这所学校以前的校友包括莫里哀和伏尔泰，还有耐人寻味的萨德侯爵，所以他也曾在那里。我查了一下，追随罗伯斯庇尔脚步的校友名单令人惊叹：维克多·雨果、萨特、罗兰·巴特、雅克·希拉克。雅克·希拉克，节目的朋友。一个喜欢快速淋浴的人。是的，五分钟先生什么的。我想是三分钟，不是吗？包括淋浴，记得吗？雅克·德里达。
so many people see is the absolute key to Rob Spears' career and indeed to the course of the French Revolution. So this is when he meets the royal couple. Well, tell the story, Tom, and tell me if it really is the key. So Louis XVI and Marie Antoinette have gone to Grins to be anointed with the holy oil and to be crowned. And they're returning from their coronation. And the boys of the college Louis Le Gris have been preparing,
好的。托马斯·皮凯蒂。所以，我的意思是，绝对是一份著名的法国作家和知识分子的名单。哇。还有雅克·希拉克。非常好。当他在学校时……正是在他在学校时，发生了这个极其著名、被神话的时刻，
you know, what sounds an unbelievably dull reception with lots of verse declamation in Latin. And Robespierre, as the prize student, has been entrusted with the task giving them a ceremonial speech of welcome. And he has to wait outside for the royal coach to arrive and it's bucketing down with rain and he's kneeling, waiting for them to arrive
许多人认为这是罗伯斯庇尔职业生涯的绝对关键，实际上也是法国大革命进程的关键。所以这就是他见到皇室夫妇的时候。嗯，讲讲这个故事，汤姆，告诉我它是否真的是关键。所以路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特去兰斯接受圣油涂抹并加冕。他们从加冕礼回来。路易大帝中学的男孩们一直在准备，
and the coach lumbers up. And because it's raining, the royal couple don't get out of the coach. They just sit in the coach and kind of smile politely. They listen to this bedraggled schoolboy give what I'm sure it's a very, very dull talk. And they, when it's delivered, they acknowledge the speech with kind of polite smiles. And then, you know, they give the signal and the carriage clatters off.
你知道，听起来是一个令人难以置信的沉闷的接待，有很多拉丁语的诗歌朗诵。罗伯斯庇尔作为获奖学生，被委托负责给他们发表欢迎的仪式演讲。他必须在外面等皇家马车到达，外面下着倾盆大雨，他跪着，等待他们的到来，
And that's the end of it. Hold on. So the version that I read sometimes is they didn't look at him. They don't care. They splash him with mud and water. No, they behave as politely as they can, but they don't want to get wet. That's reasonable. I don't think that's unreasonable. But you can see that those stories that, you know, he gets splashed with mud and everything. This is being used to explain his hostility to the monarchy and his desire to bring down the regime and all. I don't think this is true at all. Okay.
马车缓缓驶来。因为下着雨，皇室夫妇没有下车。他们只是坐在马车里，礼貌地微笑着。他们听着这个衣衫褴褛的男学生发表我敢肯定是非常、非常沉闷的演讲。当演讲结束后，他们以礼貌的微笑回应了演讲。然后，你知道，他们发出信号，马车就咔哒咔哒地走开了。
I mean, I think it probably didn't help make him into a monarchist or anything like that. But I don't think it explains what is inspiring him in the revolution because there are much, much more formative influences, as we will see. So Rovtyed does very well at school. He qualifies as a lawyer and he returns to his hometown where he makes a name for himself as a friend of the poor. He is always taking on the cases of people who can't afford legal representation. Okay. And so he makes a good name for himself. People see him as a virtuous, principled person, an admirable person. But having said that, I mean, he seems destined for a life of the
故事就结束了。等等。所以我读到的版本有时是他们没有看他。他们不在乎。他们用泥水溅了他一身。不，他们表现得尽可能礼貌，但他们不想被淋湿。这很合理。我不认为这不合理。但你可以看出那些故事，你知道，他被泥水溅到等等。这被用来解释他对君主制的敌意以及他推翻政权的愿望等等。我不认为这是真的。好的。
utmost provincial obscurity, except that Robs-Pierra himself, I think, is daring to dream. He's daring to dream of a better life and a better order for France. And the reason for this is the very familiar one that he's been reading a lot of books. Oh, that was a bad sign. But he's been reading very particular books, hasn't he? We talked about Charlotte Corday, reading Plutarch and Cornay in the previous episode. Basically, everybody in the French Revolution has read the same books, and Robespair has read all of them. Yeah, so back in the 17th century, Thomas Hobbes said that he would ban the reading of histories by the Greeks and the Romans, because it just
我的意思是，我想这可能并没有帮助他成为一个保皇党什么的。但我不认为这解释了是什么在革命中激励了他，因为有更多、更具形成性的影响，正如我们将看到的。所以罗伯斯庇尔在学校表现得非常好。他获得了律师资格，并回到了他的家乡，在那里他作为穷人的朋友而声名鹊起。他总是接手那些付不起法律代理费的人的案件。好的。所以他赢得了好名声。人们视他为一个有道德、有原则的人，一个令人钦佩的人。但话虽如此，我的意思是，他似乎注定要过一种
fostered rebellion and revolution against kings. And I think that everything that happens in the 18th century would have confirmed him in that view. So Robespierre, like Charlotte Corday and like so many other stars of the revolution, is obsessed by classical history. He becomes a huge admirer of the virtues of the Greeks and the Romans, their love of country, their determination not to allow their fellow citizens to succumb to conspiracies by evil aristocrats. And the archetype of this is Cicero, provincial upstart who comes to Rome and saves his country from Cataline, who is the archetype of a seedy aristocratic conspirator. And he is obsessed by this in a way that so many people are. He takes it very seriously and he clearly identifies with Cicero very strongly. But the person
极其平庸的省城生活，除了罗伯斯庇尔本人，我想，他敢于梦想。他敢于梦想法国拥有更美好的生活和更美好的秩序。原因是非常熟悉的，他一直在读很多书。哦，那是个坏兆头。但他一直在读非常特别的书，不是吗？我们在上一集中谈到了夏洛特·科黛阅读普鲁塔克和科内。基本上，法国大革命中的每个人都读过同样的书，而罗伯斯庇尔读过所有这些书。是的，早在17世纪，托马斯·霍布斯就说他会禁止阅读希腊人和罗马人的历史，因为这只会助长对国王的叛乱和革命。我认为18世纪发生的一切都会证实他的观点。所以罗伯斯庇尔，像夏洛特·科黛和革命中许多其他明星一样，痴迷于古典历史。他成为了希腊人和罗马人美德的崇拜者，他们对国家的热爱，他们不允许同胞屈服于邪恶贵族阴谋的决心。而这方面的原型是西塞罗，一个来到罗马并从卡提林手中拯救了国家的省城暴发户，卡提林是卑劣贵族阴谋家的原型。他以许多人那样的方式对此感到痴迷。他非常认真地对待它，并且他显然强烈地认同西塞罗。但那个人
he really loves, again a very familiar name throughout this entire. series is Rousseau, the favorite philosopher of an entire generation of revolutionaries. And Robespierre claimed that he had gone to visit Rousseau in 1778. So he wrote, I saw you in your last days, and this memory is a source of proud joy for me. So scholars are unclear whether this is actually true or not. Rousseau is about to die. So the only way that Robespier could have gone to see him, he was only 19, he would have had to skip school to go and see him. So there are lots of biographers of Robespierre who think this is unlikely,
他确实非常热爱卢梭，卢梭在整个系列中是一个非常熟悉的名字，也是整整一代革命者最推崇的哲学家。罗伯斯庇尔声称他曾在1778年去拜访过卢梭。因此他写道：我在你最后的日子里见到了你，这段记忆是我引以为傲的快乐源泉。学者们并不确定这是否属实。当时卢梭即将去世，如果罗伯斯庇尔真的去见他，那他当时只有19岁，他必须逃学才能去见他。所以罗伯斯庇尔的许多传记作者认为这不太可能，
but it's not impossible. And even if he made it up, I mean, it's kind of tribute to how passionately devoted to Rousseau-Robsbyr is. And the reason that he loves Rousseau is that Rousseau defines for Robespier the kind of the core principles that will underlie his politics throughout his entire life. And there are really three key aspects of Rousseau's philosophy that Rops Pierre comes to kind of treasure. And the ultimate one of these, the non-negotiable conviction that Rousbier holds to throughout his entire life, is that the common people are the absolute embodiment of virtue. And if that is the case, then it follows, as Rousseau puts it. And this is the second principle that Ros Biel holds to, that the first of all laws is the well-being of the people.
但这并非不可能。即使他是编造的，这也算是一种致敬，体现了罗伯斯庇尔对卢梭的热爱是多么炽热。他热爱卢梭的原因在于，卢梭为罗伯斯庇尔定义了贯穿他一生政治生涯的核心原则。卢梭的哲学中有三个关键方面是罗伯斯庇尔所珍视的。其中最根本的一点，也是罗伯斯庇尔终其一生坚持的不可动摇的信念，就是普通民众是美德的绝对化身。如果情况确实如此，那么正如卢梭所言，这也是罗伯斯庇尔坚持的第二个原则：法律的首要任务是人民的福祉。
Nothing that does not contribute to the well-being of the people should be allowed in a virtuous state. And that idealisation of the people, capital B, so important, the French Revolution. We saw a little bit of a Marat, but Robespier, even more so completely. And what Robespier also holds to very passionately, and again he gets us from Rousseau, is that history will throw up certain individuals who are peculiarly qualified to voice the will of the people. So the Volunté General, as Rousseau calls it, which in turn means that the will of the people isn't necessarily to be identified with the opinions of the majority. Yeah, I love that. So that's the very convenient. The will of the people and what the majority of people think are two very different things.
在美德之邦中，任何无助于人民福祉的事物都不应被允许。这种对人民的理想化（大写的人民）在法国大革命中非常重要。我们之前稍微提到了马拉，但罗伯斯庇尔更是如此。罗伯斯庇尔还非常热切地坚持一点，同样也是从卢梭那里学来的，即历史会涌现出某些特别有资格表达人民意志的个人。正如卢梭所称的“公意”（Volunté Générale），这意味着人民的意志并不一定等同于多数人的意见。是的，我喜欢这一点。这非常方便。人民的意志和大多数人的想法是两码事。
Yes. And this will be a kind of a trend on the left, I guess, throughout its subsist. history, that people on the bar left, you might say, are often very impatient with the people for not entirely corresponding to their sense of what the people should be. And Robs-Pier identifies very strongly with this notion. And I think it's probably not pushing the psychologising too far to say that Robsbster sees himself potentially as being such a person, someone who is qualified to articulate the will of the people. Of course.
是的。我想这会成为左翼历史上的一种趋势，即极左翼人士往往对人民感到非常不耐烦，因为人民并不完全符合他们心目中人民应有的样子。罗伯斯庇尔非常认同这一观点。我认为，如果说罗伯斯庇尔在潜意识里将自己视为这样的人——一个有资格阐明人民意志的人——这可能并不算过度心理分析。当然。
And actually, if you are the very bright boy who's a slightly unusual fit but has been brought up among the people, that might give you a sense of combined loyalty to them, but also perhaps a tiny element. I'm sure he would never have thought this himself of contempt for their views and a belief that he was better equipped to articulate what was good for them than they are themselves, don't you think? Yeah, I'm sure he would never have thought of that consciously. No, but unconsciously, he thinks, I know them. They are not maybe the best judges of their own, of their own best interests, but I do care about them and I am better equipped. I really understand them in a way they don't understand themselves. I mean, it's a pre-Marxist version of worrying about the false consciousness that the working masses have and that perhaps it takes a brilliant intellectual to penetrate this and to see what really matters. Yeah. And that the mass of the people are
事实上，如果你是一个非常聪明的男孩，虽然有点格格不入，但却是在人民中长大的，这可能会让你产生一种对他们的忠诚感，但也可能带有一丝——我相信他自己绝不会这么想——对他们观点的蔑视，以及一种认为自己比他们更有能力阐明什么对他们有利的信念，你不觉得吗？是的，我相信他绝不会有意识地这样想。不，但在潜意识里，他会想：我了解他们。他们可能不是自身利益的最佳判断者，但我确实关心他们，而且我更有能力。我确实以一种他们不了解自己的方式了解他们。我的意思是，这是一种前马克思主义的版本，担心劳动群众存在“虚假意识”，也许需要一位杰出的知识分子来洞察这一点，看到真正重要的事情。是的。而且大众是
and qualified to do that. And I do think the Robsbos-Pier kind of seized himself in those terms. And this is, I think, what explains why when the French Revolution erupts in 1789, he is desperate to be a part of it. So Ruth Skir, who wrote another biography of Robespier Fatal Purity, which is wonderfully well written. His recognition of this opportunity and the ferocity of his determination to see it was amazing. He is determined to go to Versailles, to be part of this great assembly of the various estates that Louis XVIth has summoned. And so he gets elected. He goes to Versailles as an elected representative of the people of his hometown.
没有资格做到这一点的。我确实认为罗伯斯庇尔就是这样看待自己的。我认为这解释了为什么当法国大革命在1789年爆发时，他渴望参与其中。露丝·斯基尔（Ruth Scurr）写了另一本关于罗伯斯庇尔的传记《致命的纯洁》（Fatal Purity），写得非常精彩。他意识到这个机会并表现出那种想要抓住它的强烈决心，真是令人惊叹。他决心去凡尔赛，成为路易十六召集的各等级大会的一员。于是他当选了。他作为家乡人民的民选代表去了凡尔赛。
But he is, even though he's an elected representative, he is, of course, relative to lots of other people who are assembling in Versailles, basically a nobody. I mean, he's very earnest, he's very stiff. He seems to be without much charisma at all. And yet over the course of the four years that follow the eruption of the revolution, he emerges to become one of the most celebrated figures in revolutionary France, admired and hated in equal measure. And the measure of his rise to power is something that you mentioned in your previous episode, Dominic, that on the 27th of July, 1793, France is seemingly on the verge of the verge of the moment.
但是，尽管他是民选代表，相对于在凡尔赛聚集的许多其他人来说，他基本上是个无名小卒。我的意思是，他非常认真，非常刻板。他似乎一点魅力都没有。然而，在革命爆发后的四年里，他逐渐成为法国大革命中最著名的人物之一，受到同等程度的钦佩和憎恨。你上一集提到的他崛起为权力的衡量标准，多米尼克，即1793年7月27日，法国似乎正处于
of disintegration, Robs-Pierre is elected to this proto-dictatorial body, the Committee of Public Safety. And this means that he is now one of 10 men, soon to be 12, who have been appointed to protect the nation from invasion, from counter-revolution, from economic collapse, and in effect try and save the revolution from imploding totally. And why him? I mean, what, you know, we described him, very prim, very well read, maybe a little bit priggish. Not exactly an obvious man for a national military and economic emergency. So what are the qualities that have led Robespierre to the top? What do people see in him? Well, I think there are two in particular, and both of these had been on public display from
崩溃的边缘，罗伯斯庇尔当选进入了这个准独裁机构——救国委员会。这意味着他现在是10人（很快增加到12人）中的一员，他们被任命保护国家免受入侵、反革命和经济崩溃的影响，实际上是试图拯救革命，使其不至于彻底瓦解。为什么是他？我的意思是，我们形容他非常古板，非常有学问，也许还有点自命不凡。他并不是国家军事和经济紧急状态下的明显人选。那么，是什么品质让罗伯斯庇尔登上了顶峰？人们在他身上看到了什么？嗯，我认为特别有两点，而且这两点从
his earliest days as a lawyer back in Arras. And the first of these is that he displays a remarkable consistency of principle. From the earliest days, he is kind of unswerving in his opinions. He doesn't trim, he doesn't tap, he doesn't alter them. And these principles are essentially a completely resolute commitment to popular sovereignty, to the will of the people, a profound sympathy for the people, a sense of identification with them, and an opposition to autocratic government. And the consistency with which he holds these principles makes him seem to both his friends and indeed his enemies very unusual. And it gives him a kind of austere reputation. Even those who dislike him are forced to respect him. And this is then combined with an absolute
他早年在阿拉斯做律师时就已公开展示。第一点是，他表现出了非凡的原则一致性。从一开始，他在观点上就坚定不移。他不妥协，不退缩，也不改变。这些原则本质上是对人民主权、人民意志的完全坚定的承诺，对人民的深切同情，一种与他们认同感，以及对专制政府的反对。他坚持这些原则的一致性，使他在朋友和敌人眼中都显得非常与众不同。这赋予了他一种严谨的声誉。即使是那些不喜欢他的人也不得不尊重他。这一点随后与一种绝对的
commitment to his own ferociously high moral standards. He is a unbrivable. And again, this makes him pretty much unique among all the various French revolutionaries. Obvious contrasts with Dantan, who is cheerfully, cheerfully corrupt. But basically, everyone is pocketing bribes, left, right and center. Robespier never does. And again, this makes him seem so unusual to his admirers to kind of make him seem a unique figure. And again, it's kind of redolent of Plutarch, this idea of the heroes of the early Roman Republic. who are completely austere in their personal habits, completely committed to principles of moral virtue. And he serves, I think, the revolution as a model of what civic and revolutionary
对自身极其高尚的道德标准的承诺相结合。他是不可收买的。同样，这使他在所有各种法国革命者中几乎是独一无二的。与丹东形成了鲜明的对比，丹东是那种快乐的、快乐的腐败分子。但基本上，每个人都在左右开弓地收受贿赂。罗伯斯庇尔从不这样做。同样，这使他在崇拜者眼中显得如此不同寻常，以至于他成为了一个独特的人物。这让人想起普鲁塔克笔下早期罗马共和国的英雄，他们在个人习惯上完全严谨，完全致力于道德美德的原则。我认为，他作为公民和革命
virtue could be and can be. And ever since May 1791, he's been given this magnificent nickname, the incorruptible. And maybe this takes us back to his dress, doesn't it? Because, I mean, you're talking about his consistency. He, everybody else has changed what they, I mean, they've changed their principles, they've changed their politics, they've changed their factions, and they've changed their clothes to go along with it. Yes. He's always been himself and he'll never change. Hence the stockings, I guess. He is not a man who is going to give up the fashions that he likes just to demonstrate his virtue. He doesn't need to do that. His virtue should be self-evident. And because he is seen as such an admirable person, he is the incorruptible. This reputation
美德的典范服务于革命。自1791年5月以来，他一直被赋予这个宏伟的绰号——“不可腐蚀者”。也许这让我们回到了他的着装，不是吗？因为，我的意思是，你在谈论他的一致性。他，其他所有人都改变了他们——我的意思是，他们改变了原则，改变了政治立场，改变了派系，甚至为了配合这些而改变了服装。是的。他一直是他自己，他永远不会改变。我想这就是他穿长袜的原因。他不是那种为了展示美德而放弃自己喜欢的时尚的人。他不需要那样做。他的美德应该是显而易见的。正因为他被视为如此令人钦佩的人，他才被称为“不可腐蚀者”。这种声誉
is going to prove an incredible asset for the Committee of Public Safety because it serves as an assurance to good citizens everywhere that the committee shares in Robespierre's own moral property. Robespier's kind of complete commitment to the procedures of the committee to its workings is evident from the moment that he joins it. So he attends all its meetings assiduously. He goes in at 7 o'clock in the morning to read and respond to dispatches. He returns after a long day of business at 8 o'clock in the evening. He often stays late into the night. And this is a huge commitment. And it means that with Robespierre as the kind of example of what these committee members are expected to do,
将成为救国委员会的一笔惊人资产，因为它向各地的善良公民保证，委员会分享了罗伯斯庇尔本人的道德品质。罗伯斯庇尔对委员会程序及其运作的完全承诺，从他加入的那一刻起就显而易见。他勤勉地参加所有会议。他早上7点进去阅读和回复公文。他在漫长的一天工作后，晚上8点才回来。他经常工作到深夜。这是一个巨大的承诺。这意味着，以罗伯斯庇尔作为委员会成员应如何行事的榜样，
the committee very rapidly becomes the kind of beating heart of the revolution. So its meetings are held in this green papered room in the pavilion de floor, which is a 17th century building that connected to twilery where the convention had its kind of headquarters and the Louvre. and inevitably the pavilion de floor has been renamed. It's become the pavilion de la Galliéte, the pavilion of equality. And this room with its green wallpaper is basically now the nerve center of the revolution. And the mood in it is incredibly febrile, it's fraught, it's anxious. The average age of the committee members is 30. They're often absolutely tanked up on drink.
委员会很快就成为了革命的心脏。它的会议在杜伊勒里宫的绿纸房间里举行，这是一座17世纪的建筑，连接着国民公会总部所在的杜伊勒里宫和卢浮宫。不可避免地，这座建筑被重新命名了。它变成了“平等馆”。这个贴着绿色壁纸的房间现在基本上是革命的神经中枢。里面的气氛极其狂热、紧张、焦虑。委员会成员的平均年龄是30岁。他们经常喝得酩酊大醉。
There's a general mood of panic. as well there might be because basically everything that could go wrong seems to be going wrong. So we talked about it in the previous episode. Military crisis, civil war inflation, bread sorted is. Dominic, it's like Britain in 1974. That's fantastic, Tom. That's a great comparison. You're welcome.
有一种普遍的恐慌情绪。这是理所当然的，因为基本上所有可能出错的事情似乎都在出错。所以我们在上一集讨论过。军事危机、内战、通货膨胀、面包短缺。多米尼克，这就像1974年的英国。太棒了，汤姆。这是一个很好的比较。不客气。
Who's Marcia Williams in this analogy? The incorruptible doesn't have a Marcy Williams. No, he doesn't. He's above all that. I mean, his incorruptibility is so useful at the time when people are looking for traitors because he is the one person nobody would ever suspect of being a traitor. I mean, at a point when you're saying, you know, Dumurier, the Gironde, whoever, behind the mask, they were actually plotting all along.
在这个类比中，谁是玛西娅·威廉姆斯？“不可腐蚀者”没有玛西娅·威廉姆斯。不，他没有。他超脱于这一切。我的意思是，他的不可腐蚀性在人们寻找叛徒时非常有用，因为他是唯一一个没人会怀疑是叛徒的人。我的意思是，当你在说，你知道，迪穆里埃、吉伦特派，无论谁，在面具背后，他们其实一直都在密谋。
Finally, we've found a bloke that nobody would ever, ever say that about. But he's not just there as a sort of, as a mascot, is he? He is there because he has an idea of the way out of the crisis that is going to become incredibly potent in the next few weeks and months. Yeah, so he has an explanation for what's been going wrong, but even more crucially, he has a solution. So when you're in the midst of a crisis, you want someone who can give you what seems a plausible way out of it.
终于，我们找到了一个没人会那样说的人。但他不仅仅是作为一个吉祥物，对吧？他在那里是因为他有一个摆脱危机的想法，这在接下来的几周和几个月里将变得极其强大。是的，所以他不仅对出错的原因有解释，更关键的是，他有一个解决方案。所以当你处于危机之中时，你需要一个能给你提供看似可行的摆脱困境方法的人。
And this is what Robespierre does. And it gradually enables him over the course of the weeks and the months that follow his ascension to the committee to take on an ever more preponderant role in it. And it will turn out that Robespierre isn't just a man of the utmost moral probity, not just a man with an unrivaled insight into the pathologies of the revolution, but also crucially a man who is absolutely brilliant at politics and in fact probably better at politics than any other revolutionary in France. Craigie, that's a big claim. Well, we'll come back after the break and Tom will justify. this extraordinary claim. This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude.
这就是罗伯斯庇尔所做的。这使他在加入委员会后的几周和几个月里，逐渐在委员会中扮演了越来越重要的角色。事实证明，罗伯斯庇尔不仅是一个道德极其高尚的人，不仅是一个对革命病理有无与伦比洞察力的人，而且至关重要的是，他是一个在政治上绝对出色的人，事实上可能比法国任何其他革命者都更擅长政治。天哪，这可是个大话。好吧，休息后回来，汤姆将证明这个非凡的说法。本集由Anthropic赞助，Claude背后的团队。
Now, history's biggest leaps, many of them started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that, Tom, at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus, great pioneering voyage of discovery, and it is of course the Americas. So, Anthropic knows the importance of questions, and it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard
现在，历史上最大的飞跃，其中许多始于人们不想问的难题。是的，汤姆，15世纪末有一个经典的例子。那个难题特别就是：大西洋西岸之外有什么？正如你所知，找到那个问题答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布，伟大的先驱发现之旅，当然，那就是美洲。所以，Anthropic知道问题的重要性，这就是为什么Anthropic建立在一个难题之上
question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution really goes well for ordinary people? Anthropic asked 100,000 people, and what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? Can kids have a better future? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clod.AI slash rest is history. And keep thinking. On that flight with 350 passengers. We assess Prime Minister with high confidence it was Russian.
首先是问题。我们如何确保人工智能革命对普通人来说真的进展顺利？Anthropic询问了10万人，得到的不仅仅是恐惧。还有希望。人们想知道，癌症会被治愈吗？孩子们能有更好的未来吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。在clod.AI/rest is history提出你的问题。并继续思考。在那架载有350名乘客的航班上。我们以高置信度评估首相，那是俄罗斯人。
Holding the Russians accountable is World War III. They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people. Man in the Kremlin is playing, Alex. Got to ask yourself, you want to play. or not? You're the Prime Minister. You've done nothing! We would need to understand the policy context.
让俄罗斯人负责就是第三次世界大战。他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。克里姆林宫的那个人在玩弄，亚历克斯。你得问问自己，你想玩吗？你是首相。你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。
All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today. Kill the President of Russia. Yes. Who is going to be able to pull this off? Sergeant Tom McDonough! Devised as a technically rigorous, geopolitical action thriller. We have two-town friendly key. Where Britain plays its strongest hand.
今天所有相关的背景都将构建为一个框架。杀死俄罗斯总统。是的。谁能做到这一点？汤姆·麦克多诺中士！被设计为一部技术严谨的地缘政治动作惊悚片。我们有双城友好关键。英国打出了最强的一张牌。
He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Bear Hunt. Available now in full, wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. Think of some things that glow.
他是最棒的。对抗它最强大的敌人。猎熊行动。现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方完整收听。嘿，这是来自Gollhangers的迈克尔和汉娜。休息是科学。本集由英国癌症研究中心为您带来。想想一些会发光的东西。
Okay, fireflies, glow sticks, the northern lights. They're very cool. But what if we could replicate that glow inside our bodies and what if doing so could help us save lives? Because Cancer Research UK scientists, they're investigating whether a special fluorescent dye that sticks to prostate cancer cells could tackle an ongoing challenge in the operating room, removing every single trace of cancer. Because when cancer cells are glowing and easy to spot,
好吧，萤火虫、荧光棒、北极光。它们非常酷。但如果我们能在体内复制这种光芒，如果这样做能帮助我们拯救生命呢？因为英国癌症研究中心的科学家们正在研究一种能粘附在癌细胞上的特殊荧光染料，是否能解决手术室中一个持续存在的挑战：清除每一丝癌细胞。因为当癌细胞发光且容易被发现时，
surgeons can precisely remove them, leaving healthy cells untouched, meaning there's less chance of the cancer returning and fewer nasty side effects. Cancer Research UK's vision is a world where everybody lives longer, better lives free from the fear of cancer, with breakthroughs like this leading to kinder, more effective treatments. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research and breakthroughs and how you can support them, visitcancerachuk.org slash restis science. Hi everybody, welcome back to the Restis History. It is the 26th of July 1793. So we are 13 days after the murder of Mecca. And this is the evening before Maximilier-Robst
外科医生可以精确地切除它们，让健康细胞不受影响，这意味着癌症复发的几率更小，副作用也更少。英国癌症研究中心的愿景是一个每个人都能活得更长、更好，免于癌症恐惧的世界，像这样的突破带来了更温和、更有效的治疗方法。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究和突破以及如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问cancerachuk.org/restis science。大家好，欢迎回到“休息是历史”。现在是1793年7月26日。所以我们距离马拉被谋杀已经13天了。这是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔的前一天晚上
joins the Committee of Public Safety. And let's zoom in on one house in Paris, in the Rue Saint-Hon-Ré. It's a small two-story house. It's a few minutes walk away from the Jacobin Club, where the radicals meet in the convent of the Jacqueline. And this is the house where a cabinet maker lives called Maurice DuPlet and his family.
加入救国委员会。让我们聚焦于巴黎圣奥诺雷街的一所房子。这是一座两层的小房子。距离激进分子在雅各宾修道院聚会的雅各宾俱乐部只有几分钟的步行路程。这就是一位名叫莫里斯·杜普莱的木匠和他的家人居住的房子。
He's a joiner, and he's also a very keen radical. And he has a lodger, and the name of that lodger, is of course Maximilier Robespierierierierierierre. And Tom, he's been there for two years, and he loves it, doesn't he? He loves the DuPlaes. He does. He admires Maurice DuPier as a kind of example of the working classes for whom Ross Pierre is fighting. But also, there is a Madame DuPlai, and she has three daughters, and they just fuss and fuss over Robs of Pierre.
他是一名细木工，也是一位非常热心的激进分子。他有一位房客，那位房客的名字当然是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。汤姆，他已经在那里住了两年了，他很喜欢那里，不是吗？他喜欢杜普莱一家。他确实喜欢。他钦佩莫里斯·杜普莱，认为他是罗伯斯庇尔正在为之奋斗的工人阶级的典范。而且，还有一位杜普莱夫人，她有三个女儿，她们对罗伯斯庇尔照顾得无微不至。
And he absolutely adores this. So to quote Charlotte's sister, who was actually very jealous of. of the women in the DuPlay family. They expressed towards him the most vivid interest and surrounded him with their thousand delicate concerns. He was extremely susceptible to all these sorts of things. So he doesn't just have one, Marcia Williams. He's got three.
他非常喜欢这一点。引用夏洛特的妹妹的话，她实际上非常嫉妒杜普莱家的女性。她们对他表达了最强烈的兴趣，并用她们成千上万种细腻的关怀包围着他。他非常容易受到这些事情的影响。所以他不仅有一个玛西娅·威廉姆斯。他有三个。
But his relationship with them is above suspicion. So pure. Purely platonic. And his own room is very, very Spartan, which is exactly how he likes it. So there's a bed, there's a writing table, there's some bookshel. absolutely nothing else. So it is a suitably ascetic retreat for the incorruptible. Nobody ever hints
但他与她们的关系无可挑剔。如此纯洁。纯粹是柏拉图式的。他自己的房间非常、非常简朴，这正是他喜欢的样子。所以有一张床，一张写字台，一些书架。绝对没有其他东西。所以这是一个适合“不可腐蚀者”的苦行隐居处。没有人暗示
at any impropriety in Ros Pierre's relationship with the women of the DuPlay family. Just going to emphasize that. So he's in his room and that evening he sits down at his desk and he ponderes the terrible crisis that is facing France and the revolution. So there are foreign armies on French soil, the Austrian, the Prussians. There is a British name. naval blockade. There is a mass insurrection in Vonday. We heard about that in the last episode. There are counter-revolutionary uprisings, federalist uprisings, historians call them, in cities that include Lyon, Marseille, and crucially the great naval base of Toulon, where the British Navy is hovering on the margins. And of course, there are food shortages
罗伯斯庇尔与杜普莱家女性的关系有任何不当之处。我只是想强调这一点。所以他在房间里，那天晚上他坐在书桌前，思考着法国和革命面临的可怕危机。法国领土上有外国军队，奥地利人、普鲁士人。还有英国的封建海军封锁。旺代发生了大规模起义。我们在上一集听说了。还有反革命起义，历史学家称之为联邦主义者起义，发生在包括里昂、马赛在内的城市，以及至关重要的土伦海军基地，英国海军就在边缘徘徊。当然，还有食物短缺
in Paris. And so there are demonstrations in the streets all the time. Robespierreyses this, and then he draws up, well, let's call it a catechism. You know, the kind of the religious quality of the most radical revolutionaries, I think is very evident. And this is an example. And what Rob Spierre is trying to do is to define the precise challenges that he will be facing as a member of the committee of public safety, which he's going to be joining the following day. And so he writes, question, what is our aim, answer, to provide governance for the benefit of the people? And the people, of course, for Robs-Pierre are the great embodiment of virtue.
在巴黎。所以街上一直有示威活动。罗伯斯庇尔分析了这一点，然后他起草了一份——嗯，我们称之为教义问答吧。你知道，我认为最激进的革命者身上那种宗教色彩非常明显。这就是一个例子。罗伯斯庇尔试图做的是定义他作为救国委员会成员将面临的具体挑战，他第二天就要加入该委员会。于是他写道：问题，我们的目标是什么？回答，为人民的利益提供治理。而对于罗伯斯庇尔来说，人民当然是美德的伟大化身。
And this is a principle that he's absorbed from Rousseau and which he will never abandon. This assumption that the poor are intrinsically good, they can do no wrong. But there is a problem, which is the France is facing massive popular insurrections in the provinces. And so this requires Robespier to answer an obvious question. if the people are intrinsically good, why are they behaving in such a way? Why are they refusing to behave in a kind of the selfless and patriotic manner that they probably should be if they are intrinsically virtuous? And Ross Pierre's answer to this puzzle is that they are being kept in ignorance and poverty by the rich and the corrupt. So it's a sort of version of our old friend false consciousness, but one that has been done.
这是一个他从卢梭那里吸收并永远不会放弃的原则。这种假设认为穷人本质上是善良的，他们不会做错事。但有一个问题，那就是法国在各省面临着大规模的人民起义。因此，这要求罗伯斯庇尔回答一个显而易见的问题：如果人民本质上是善良的，为什么他们表现得如此？为什么他们拒绝表现出那种无私和爱国的态度，如果他们本质上是美德的，他们本应该表现出这种态度？罗伯斯庇尔对这个谜题的回答是，他们被富人和腐败分子保持在无知和贫困之中。所以这是一种我们老朋友“虚假意识”的版本，但这种意识是被
much more deliberately and malevolently contrived by this coalition of the enemies of France. And specifically of the poor. So he's saying, you know, who are the chief obstacles to the enlightenment of the poor? Yeah. The paid journalists who misleads them every day by shameless distortions. I'm very familiar with that argument, I have to say. That is very... So in other words, if only people weren't reading awful columnists,
由法国敌人的联盟更蓄意、更恶意地策划的。特别是穷人的敌人。所以他在说，你知道，谁是穷人启蒙的主要障碍？是的。每天用无耻的歪曲误导他们的付费记者。我必须说，我对那个论点非常熟悉。那是非常……换句话说，如果人们不读那些糟糕的专栏作家，
in the Daily Mail. Yeah. Everything will be perfect. That's absolutely Robespier's vibe. Robespier also blames turncoat generals like Lafayette and De Morier, both of whom have defected from the revolution to foreign enemies. Yeah. The British, who Robs pierre describes as an insolent and vile people, and particularly
在《每日邮报》上。是的。一切都会变得完美。这绝对是罗伯斯庇尔的氛围。罗伯斯庇尔还指责像拉法耶特和迪穆里埃这样的变节将军，他们都背叛了革命，投向了外国敌人。是的。英国人，罗伯斯庇尔称他们为傲慢而卑鄙的人民，特别是
their Prime Minister, William Pitt, who is seen as flooding France with gold. And the temptation to blame everything that is happening. on France, on pits gold is a very strong one, to which revolutionaries will repeatedly succumb. And Robespierre also blames traitors and conspirators. And these are perhaps the most pernicious enemies of all, because these are monsters who wear the show of patriotism, but who secretly beneath the surface are working for the overthrow of the revolution. And just on that, here's a man thing. It is often said in the final months of 1793 or early 1794, The more keen somebody appears to be on the revolution, the more likely it is that they are a traitor.
他们的首相威廉·皮特，他被视为用黄金淹没了法国。将发生的一切归咎于法国、归咎于皮特的黄金的诱惑是非常强烈的，革命者会反复屈服于这种诱惑。罗伯斯庇尔还指责叛徒和阴谋家。这些也许是最有害的敌人，因为这些怪物披着爱国主义的外衣，但在表面之下却秘密地为推翻革命而工作。关于这一点，这里有一件男人的事情。在1793年的最后几个月或1794年初，人们常说：一个人表现得越热衷于革命，他就越有可能是叛徒。
They're protesting too much. Yeah. And so Robespierrear draws up this list of all the enemies that France is facing. And he comes to the conclusion that all these perils, they're not just a kind of concatenation of distinct and separate crises, but rather the expression of a kind of omni crisis, you might call it. A singular conspiracy that has multiple tentacles and that these tentacles are reaching out to throttle the revolution wherever it can get a grip. And there is a clarity to this perspective, a kind of a purity and starkness, which when he goes
他们抗议得太多了。是的。于是罗伯斯庇尔列出了法国面临的所有敌人。他得出的结论是，所有这些危险，不仅仅是一系列不同且独立的危机，而是某种“全危机”的表达，你可以这样称呼它。一个单一的阴谋，有多个触角，这些触角正在伸出，试图在任何能抓住的地方扼杀革命。这种观点有一种清晰度，一种纯洁和严酷，当他去
to join the Committee of Public Safety and presents it to them, his fellow members find very appealing. Yeah. And in fact, probably this is why they've co-opted him. Well, this idea of the Omni conspiracy, you know, that everything is related and that absolutely everything comes back to this conspiracy. This is going to run through this episode and the next four episodes. You know, this is what explains his motivation and that of some of his colleagues, that they genuinely, they genuinely believe it, don't they? Yeah. They have fallen down the YouTube rubber hole and they genuinely think that these people, these people, these people,
加入救国委员会并向他们展示时，他的同事们觉得非常有吸引力。是的。事实上，这可能就是他们拉拢他的原因。嗯，这个“全阴谋”的想法，你知道，一切都是相关的，绝对一切都归结于这个阴谋。这将贯穿这一集和接下来的四集。你知道，这就是解释他的动机以及他的一些同事动机的原因，他们真诚地，他们真诚地相信这一点，不是吗？是的。他们掉进了YouTube的兔子洞，他们真诚地认为这些人，这些人，这些人，
who actually don't know each other at all, are all working in one plot and actually William Pitts is paying for it. Yeah, that's exactly what he thinks. And because of his moral reputation and because of the clarity with which he expresses it, I mean, he doesn't, he's not accepted immediately as the leader of the committee. And his fellow members don't agree with him on every point. But it does mean that his understanding of the crisis facing the revolution and what is taken to fight it becomes, increasingly influential. Well, it's very simple. It's very simple. It's very attractive. Yeah, because a simple policy is always the most welcome. Yeah. You don't want to faff around with dealing with multiple contingencies. You want a nice, clear answer that explains everything. Completely. And so there are two men on the committee in particular who are massive Robespierre fans. And let's just look at them because they're going to play an important role in the story that we're
他们其实根本不认识对方，都在同一个阴谋中工作，而且实际上是威廉·皮特在付钱。是的，他就是这么想的。由于他的道德声誉以及他表达观点的清晰度，我的意思是，他并没有立即被接受为委员会的领导人。他的同事们并不在每一个点上都同意他。但这确实意味着他对革命面临的危机的理解以及为之奋斗的手段变得越来越有影响力。嗯，这很简单。这非常简单。这非常有吸引力。是的，因为简单的政策总是最受欢迎的。是的。你不想为了处理多种突发事件而忙乱。你想要一个清晰、明确的答案，解释一切。完全是这样。所以委员会里特别有两个人是罗伯斯庇尔的铁杆粉丝。让我们看看他们，因为他们将在我们
going to be telling over the course of the terror. So the first of these, Dominic, you quoted him several times in episode one. It's a guy called Georges Couton. So he's 38, so three years older than Robs-Pierre when Robs-Pier joins the committee. And he's a lawyer from the Avern in the south of France. And all his life, he had suffered from bad joints, bad sinews. And unfortunately, by 1793, he's effectively paralyzed below the way, so he's confined to a wheelchair. And what had caused this, his doctors had diagnosed meningitis. But Couton himself blamed this condition on having had too much sex as a young man. And whether he says that because it sounds slightly more glamorous explanation for his condition than meningitis, I don't know whether he
在恐怖统治期间讲述的故事中扮演重要角色。所以第一个，多米尼克，你在第一集中引用过他好几次。他叫乔治·库东。他38岁，比罗伯斯庇尔加入委员会时大三岁。他是法国南部奥弗涅的一名律师。他一生都患有关节和肌腱疾病。不幸的是，到1793年，他腰部以下实际上已经瘫痪，所以他被限制在轮椅上。是什么导致了这种情况？他的医生诊断为脑膜炎。但库东本人将这种情况归咎于年轻时性生活过多。至于他这么说是因为这听起来比脑膜炎更迷人，还是他
genuinely believed it. Did that weaken his joints? Did that also explain the bad joints? I don't know. I wasn't aware that that was a consequence of it, but maybe it is. Lessoners can absorb that lesson as they wish. I mean, you think he's a lovely man, don't you? This guy, Couton. I don't. I'm reporting the general consensus on Couton, which is people find find him very in private, charming, affable. Like Rospier, he's a bit of a sentimentalist, but unlike Rospier, he has a sense of humour. He's a fun person to be with. So he's a funster.
真诚地相信这一点，我不知道。那会削弱他的关节吗？那也能解释关节不好吗？我不知道。我不知道那是后果，但也许是。听众可以随心所欲地吸收这个教训。我的意思是，你认为他是个可爱的人，不是吗？这个库东。我不认为。我是在报道关于库东的普遍共识，即人们发现他在私下里很迷人、和蔼可亲。像罗伯斯庇尔一样，他有点多愁善感，但与罗伯斯庇尔不同的是，他有幽默感。他是一个有趣的人。所以他是一个有趣的人。
Great. He's a funster. But as a politician, he completely buys into Robespier's diagnosis and the cure. Yeah. The other big Rospier fan on the committee is perhaps the most glamorous of all its members. And this is a guy who's only 25. So the baby of the committee. And this is a guy called Louis Antoine de Saint-Just.
太棒了。他是一个有趣的人。但作为一名政治家，他完全接受罗伯斯庇尔的诊断和治疗方法。是的。委员会里另一个罗伯斯庇尔的铁杆粉丝也许是其成员中最迷人的。这是一个只有25岁的人。所以是委员会里的“婴儿”。这个人叫路易·安托万·德·圣茹斯特。
And he's very dandyish, very handsome, kind of rock star vibe. He's like a kind of young Mick Jagger. Long hair. Long hair loves to sing in Italian aria. He's always doing that. But he's also very, very chill, very self-disciplined, implacably committed to his values, to his beliefs in a very Rospierre fashion. And in fact, he has been very influenced.
他非常讲究，非常英俊，有一种摇滚明星的氛围。他就像一个年轻的米克·贾格尔。长发。长发，喜欢唱意大利咏叹调。他总是那样做。但他也非常、非常冷静，非常有自律，以一种非常罗伯斯庇尔的方式坚定地致力于他的价值观和信仰。事实上，他深受
by Robespierre. So he had written to the great man back in 1790, actually when Robespier wasn't really a great man. He kind of talent spotted him at a very early age. And San Jus had written to Robespier, I do not know you, but you are a great man. You were not merely the deputy of a province. You are the deputy of the republic and of mankind. And you can imagine how this goes down with Robespier. He thinks this is brilliant. Yeah, of course. So he and San Jus become very close. But I think San Jus is actually much more intellectually formidable than Robespierre. And he becomes the great ideologue of the revolution at its most violent. And he will come to be given this nickname, the Archangel of Terror, which I think brilliantly
罗伯斯庇尔的影响。所以他早在1790年就写信给这位伟人，当时罗伯斯庇尔还不是什么伟人。他在很小的时候就发现了他的才华。圣茹斯特写信给罗伯斯庇尔：我不认识你，但你是一个伟人。你不仅仅是一个省的代表。你是共和国和人类的代表。你可以想象这对罗伯斯庇尔意味着什么。他认为这太棒了。是的，当然。所以他和圣茹斯特变得非常亲密。但我认为圣茹斯特在智力上实际上比罗伯斯庇尔更强大。他成为了革命在最暴力时期的伟大思想家。他将被赋予这个绰号——“恐怖大天使”，我认为这非常精彩地
conveys the sense of glamour that comes to attach itself to him. And Saint-Jouz is the model for almost the kind of the byronic terrorist that haunts the pages of Dostoevsky or people like that. the sense that there is a poetry in terror that risks consuming the world. He's like somebody from the Bardemeynhoff group or some American fringe group in the 1970s. Long hair, he's quite cool, he's terrifying, he's ruthless, he's cold-blooded. Well, it's simultaneously cold when it comes to condemning other people to death, but there is something about him that gets other people very excited.
传达了附着在他身上的那种魅力感。圣茹斯特是那种困扰陀思妥耶夫斯基或类似作家笔下的拜伦式恐怖分子的典范。那种恐怖中存在着一种可能吞噬世界的诗意。他就像巴德-迈因霍夫集团或1970年代美国边缘团体的某个人。长发，他很酷，他很可怕，他很无情，他冷血。嗯，在谴责其他人死刑时，他同时是冷酷的，但他身上确实有一些东西让其他人感到非常兴奋。
But I think also in the 19th and then into the 20th century, what gives him this glamour is the sense that he, more than perhaps anybody else involved in the revolution, is a precursor of communist revolution. Yes, completely. He's an avatar of what is to come. So Robsvier had these two very, very charismatic allies, and they obviously provide him with political support on the committee. Rosbier has his own sense of destiny and of self-assurance, and so he comes to take an ever more commanding position on the committee.
但我认为在19世纪和20世纪，赋予他这种魅力的是这样一种感觉：他比革命中涉及的任何其他人更像是共产主义革命的先驱。是的，完全是。他是未来事物的化身。所以罗伯斯庇尔有这两个非常有魅力的盟友，他们显然在委员会中为他提供了政治支持。罗伯斯庇尔有自己的命运感和自信心，所以他在委员会中占据了越来越主导的地位。
And already only a few days after he has joined the committee, an observer at one of their meetings, could describe Rob Speer's colleagues and, I quote, as silent in the face of his words and his principles. So these words and principles, I mean, what is he saying? He's talking about the people, presumably. He's talking about how much he believes in them. He's talking about the conspiracy. But what else? Well, I think his fundamental principles are admirable ones.
就在他加入委员会几天后，一位在会议现场的观察员可以这样描述罗伯斯庇尔的同事们，我引用：“面对他的言辞和原则，他们保持沉默。”所以这些言辞和原则，我的意思是，他在说什么？他大概是在谈论人民。他在谈论他有多么相信他们。他在谈论阴谋。但还有什么？嗯，我认为他的基本原则是令人钦佩的。
he has a firm faith in democracy and in constitutional government. And Dominant, you mentioned very briefly in the first episode that a new constitution was being celebrated as Charlotte Corday arrived in Paris. And this constitution had been drawn up by Robespierre, abetted by Saint-Joust and Couton. And they'd done it in record time. They'd drawn it up in early June. And its provisions were ones that Robespierre absent. absolutely believed in. It offers a commitment to universal male suffrage without any qualification, free public education, which is to be funded by progressive taxation. And it declares as a matter of national principle that the state has a duty of care towards its most unfortunate citizens. So this is, and I don't think it's anachronism to use this phrase, the most progressive constitution that history has ever. ever seen up to this point. Yeah. I mean, it's the kind of thing that progressives in any Western
他对民主和宪政政府有着坚定的信念。多米尼克，你在第一集中非常简短地提到，当夏洛特·科黛到达巴黎时，一部新宪法正在庆祝。这部宪法是由罗伯斯庇尔起草的，圣茹斯特和库东协助。他们以创纪录的时间完成了它。他们在6月初起草了它。其条款是罗伯斯庇尔绝对相信的。它承诺在没有任何资格限制的情况下实行普遍男性选举权，实行免费公共教育，由累进税资助。它宣布作为一项国家原则，国家有义务照顾其最不幸的公民。所以这是——我不认为使用这个短语是时代错误——历史上见过的最进步的宪法。
state today would very happily vote for, I think. And the French people themselves vote for it, don't they? They have a referendum, and by a massive majority, they endorse it. They do. So this is held throughout June and July, and the results are announced on the 10th of August, which is the anniversary of the abolition of the monarchy. And it turns out that almost two million people have voted in favor of it and only 11,600 against it. And so Robespierre is delighted. It's now been proven that he is the voice of the people. They completely back him. And since he has sent, you know, he essentially is the author of this constitution, of course he wants to see it put into action. The problem is that he feels that France is not yet ready for it, not with
是的。我的意思是，这是今天任何西方国家的进步人士都会非常乐意投票支持的事情，我想。法国人民自己也投票支持它，不是吗？他们举行了全民公投，以压倒性多数通过了它。他们确实通过了。所以这在6月和7月期间举行，结果在8月10日宣布，那是废除君主制的周年纪念日。结果显示，近200万人投票支持，只有11,600人反对。所以罗伯斯庇尔很高兴。现在已经证明他是人民的声音。他们完全支持他。既然他发送了，你知道，他本质上是这部宪法的作者，当然他希望看到它付诸实施。问题是他觉得法国还没有准备好，不是因为
the revolution being menaced by a conspiracy that threatens to destroy it altogether. And so, he says, what we must do is first defeat the conspiracy and then introduce the Constitution. And sure enough, in the event, so on the 10th of September 1793, the Constitution will end up being officially suspended. Yeah. And Robespierre completely backs this. And it's due reflection of the fact that the, you know, the revolution is facing massive crisis of challenges everywhere.
革命受到一个威胁要彻底摧毁它的阴谋的威胁。所以，他说，我们必须做的是首先击败阴谋，然后引入宪法。果然，在事件中，所以1793年9月10日，宪法最终被正式暂停。是的。罗伯斯庇尔完全支持这一点。这是对革命在各地面临大规模危机挑战这一事实的充分反映。
And Robespierre feels that the focus should be not in introducing the Constitution, but rather on defeating this kind of hydra-headed conspiracy that is threatening to destroy it completely. But this brings us, doesn't it, Tom, to the terror, to the brain of terror. So how to defeat the conspiracy. And his strategy here is implacable and ruthless. And, I mean, am I exaggerating, do you think, to describe it as he's going to mobilize all. the resources of society, effectively every man, woman and child in the kind of national effort to root out conspiracy and any deviation from the path of revolutionary righteousness. Well, if you were going to defeat a conspiracy that is menacing the people, you need the people in their entirety to defeat it. So let me read what he wrote in the catechism, you know,
罗伯斯庇尔觉得重点不应该放在引入宪法上，而应该放在击败这种威胁要彻底摧毁它的多头阴谋上。但这把我们带到了恐怖，带到了恐怖的大脑，不是吗，汤姆？那么如何击败阴谋呢。他在这里的策略是坚定不移和无情的。而且，我的意思是，你认为我夸张了吗，将其描述为他将动员社会的所有资源，实际上是每一个男人、女人和孩子，进行某种全国性的努力，以根除阴谋和任何偏离革命正义道路的行为。嗯，如果你要击败一个威胁人民的阴谋，你需要全体人民来击败它。所以让我读读他在教义问答中写的内容，你知道，
that he was drawing up on the evening before he joined the Committee of Public Safety. And this is a very brutal prescription for ending the crisis. So he wrote, how can we end the civil war by punishing traitors and conspirators, especially those deputies and administrators who are to blame, by sending patriot troops under patriot leaders to reduce the aristocrats of Lyon, Marseille, Toulon, the Vonday, and all other districts where the banner of royalism and rebellion has been raised, and by making a terrible example of all the criminals who have outraged liberty and spilt the blood of patriots. And that is a potentially exterminatory policy. And it is very obviously one that contradicts Rob's PS deeply held and often expressed opposition to capital punishment.
他在加入公共安全委员会的前一天晚上起草的。这是一份结束危机的极其残酷的处方。因此他写道，我们如何通过惩罚叛徒和阴谋家，特别是那些应受指责的代表和行政人员，通过派遣爱国军队在爱国将领的领导下镇压里昂、马赛、土伦、旺代以及所有其他竖起保皇主义和叛乱旗帜的地区的贵族，并通过对所有亵渎自由、挥洒爱国者鲜血的罪犯处以极刑来杀一儆百，从而结束内战。这是一种潜在的灭绝性政策。而且这显然与罗伯斯庇尔根深蒂固且经常表达的反对死刑的立场背道而驰。
And so listeners may be wondering, well, what impact does this have on his reputation for unyielding principle? And the answer is, it has no impact whatsoever. And the reason for this is that even as Robespierre has been saying he's opposed to the death penalty, he has also right from the very beginning of the revolution back in 1789 been arguing that to live through a revolution changes everything, that there might come a time when civilized norms would need to be suspended and that the end must justify the means. And because he has been arguing this since 1789 at a time where this prescription. was unthinkable to most enthusiasts for the revolution. It gives him the moral authority to push this policy and not to seem like he's just kind of, you know, dreamt it up as a way of buttressing his own power. So as late as the trial of Louis the 16th for which Robespier had voted, he'd expressed his hope that Louis's execution would be the last that the revolution would require that there would be no need for the state to mandate the putting to death of any
听众可能想知道，这对他在坚持原则方面的声誉有什么影响？答案是，没有任何影响。原因在于，尽管罗伯斯庇尔一直声称他反对死刑，但从1789年革命一开始，他就一直在论证，经历一场革命会改变一切，可能会有文明规范需要暂停的时候，目的必须证明手段的正当性。因为他自1789年以来就一直这样论证，当时这种处方对大多数革命狂热者来说是不可想象的。这赋予了他推动这项政策的道德权威，而不至于让人觉得他只是为了巩固自己的权力而凭空捏造出来的。所以直到路易十六的审判（罗伯斯庇尔投了赞成票），他仍表示希望路易的处决是革命所需要的最后一次，国家无需再下令处死任何人。
further person. But as you said in the previous episode, the thing that changes everything is the defection of Dumorier, this former Girondin minister who had won great victories for the French Republic, but then had kind of turned coat, gone over to the enemies of France, and which had been interpreted by Robespierre as by Jacobin, and Montignyre and people like that, as a potentially mortal blow to the revolution. And because it's a potentially mortal blow, that means that those who are responsible for it cannot possibly be treated with mercy. So to quote Roz-Pierre, for every attempt made against the security of the state or the liberty,
但正如你在上一集所说，改变一切的是迪穆里埃的叛逃，这位曾为法兰西共和国赢得伟大胜利的前吉伦特派部长，后来却倒戈投向了法国的敌人，这被罗伯斯庇尔、雅各宾派、山岳派等人解读为对革命的潜在致命打击。因为这是一种潜在的致命打击，意味着那些对此负责的人绝不可能得到宽恕。引用罗伯斯庇尔的话，对于每一次针对国家安全或共和国的自由、
equality, unity and indivisibility of the republic, capital punishment is now the only appropriate punishment. And people understand that this goes against his opposition to capital punishment, but But they kind of respect the fact that he's prepared to sacrifice that principle on the much greater principle, which is that the revolution must be saved. And so he's not seen as someone who is kind of shifting his position. He's being seen as someone who is who is cleaving to the ultimate needs of the revolution, even if that comes as moral cost to himself.
平等、统一和不可分割性的企图，死刑现在是唯一适当的惩罚。人们明白这违背了他对死刑的反对立场，但他们尊重他为了更伟大的原则——即必须拯救革命——而准备牺牲这一原则的事实。因此，他并没有被视为一个改变立场的人，而是被视为一个即使以牺牲自己的道德代价为代价，也要坚持革命终极需求的人。
I mean, one of the points actually is that in the next few months, he and Sanjou spent a lot of time making speeches to explain their rationale. One of the points they make is that if you oppose the government, if you're undermining the national war effort, and therefore you're obviously working for the foreign conspiracy, you don't really count as a citizen because true citizens would be with us. And if you are not a citizen, then all our talk of, despite their idea that the human rights stuff is universal, they sort of have their care you need it because they say, if you're not a citizen and you're a foreign traitor, then all the right stuff doesn't apply to you.
我的意思是，其中一点实际上是，在接下来的几个月里，他和圣茹斯特花了很多时间发表演讲来解释他们的基本原理。他们提出的观点之一是，如果你反对政府，如果你在破坏国家的战争努力，因此你显然是在为外国阴谋工作，那么你就不算是一个公民，因为真正的公民会和我们站在一起。如果你不是公民，那么我们关于人权是普遍的这一理念，他们就得按需处理，因为他们说，如果你不是公民，而是一个外国叛徒，那么所有的权利都不适用于你。
you don't have any rights under the law so we can do whatever we want to you. This citizenship depends on, as it were, political correctness. Well, virtue, I think. They do explicitly say that kind of virtue without teeth is worth nothing. Of course, yes. And that therefore terror is a manifestation of virtue. I mean, we'll probably come to this when we look at what happens with d'Anton. But this idea that terror is a manifestation of virtue, this is a principle that is starting
你在法律下没有任何权利，所以我们可以对你做任何我们想做的事。这种公民身份取决于，怎么说呢，政治正确。嗯，我认为是美德。他们确实明确表示，没有牙齿的美德一文不值。当然，是的。因此，恐怖是美德的一种表现。我的意思是，当我们审视丹东身上发生的事情时，我们可能会谈到这一点。但这种认为恐怖是美德表现的观念，是一个开始
to evolve across the summer of 1793. And interestingly, its initial focus is in the field of military affairs, which is absolutely not Robespier's by B' at all. I mean, he has no experience of military matters whatsoever. But he supports the sending on the 4th of August of twin armies to crush insurrections in the two key counter-revolutionary outbreaks, one in Lyon, one in Marseille. And Leo is invested on the 7th of August and the second of August. siege of that city will drag on for months, but Marseilles is reduced to obedience very rapidly,
在1793年夏天演变的原则。有趣的是，它最初的重点是在军事事务领域，这绝对不是罗伯斯庇尔的专长。我的意思是，他完全没有军事事务的经验。但他支持在8月4日派遣两支军队去镇压两个关键的反革命爆发点的起义，一个是里昂，一个是马赛。里昂在8月7日被围困，对该市的围攻将持续数月，但马赛很快就被迫服从，
so it's occupied on the 25th of August, and there are mass reprisals, and Marseille itself loses its name, and it's kind of renamed Vils enumneum, so kind of the town without a name. And two days before Marseille capitulates to the forces of the revolution, the National Convention had taken a massive, massive step, a step that will resonate, not just through the history of the revolution, but through the entire future of industrial warfare. They enact a levé-on mass. So this is the first mass conscription of the modern age. And its prescription, I mean, is people who have read about the war efforts of the competence in the First or Second World Wars will recognize this. So it says, the young men shall go to battle. The married men shall
所以它在8月25日被占领，并进行了大规模的报复，马赛本身也失去了名字，被改名为“无名城”。在马赛向革命军队投降的前两天，国民公会采取了一个巨大的、巨大的步骤，这一步骤不仅将在革命史上产生共鸣，而且将贯穿整个工业战争的未来。他们颁布了“全民皆兵令”。这是现代史上第一次大规模征兵。它的处方，我的意思是，读过第一次或第二次世界大战参战国战争努力的人会认出这一点。它说，年轻人应奔赴战场。已婚男子应
forge arms and transport provision. The women shall make tents and clothes and shall serve in the hospitals. The children shall turn old linen into lint. The old men shall repair to the public places to stimulate the courage of the warriors and preach the unity of the republic and hatred of kings. So it is a seismic moment for the first time. An entire nation is being summoned to arms. And in the long run, this levee en masse will make France effectively invincible in battle for decades, because France has by far the largest reserves of manpower of any country in Europe. And so by summoning it to arms, it makes itself completely irresistible in battle. This is the bedrock, the foundation stone and the Napoleonic Empire.
锻造武器并运输补给。妇女应制作帐篷和衣服，并在医院服务。儿童应将旧亚麻布变成绷带。老人应前往公共场所，激发战士的勇气，宣扬共和国的统一和对国王的仇恨。这是一个震撼性的时刻，整个国家第一次被召集起来拿起武器。从长远来看，这种全民皆兵令将使法国在未来几十年里在战场上实际上立于不败之地，因为法国拥有欧洲各国中最大的兵力储备。因此，通过召集它拿起武器，它在战场上变得完全不可阻挡。这是拿破仑帝国的基石。
Yes, it is. But the immediate circumstances in which this levee is summoned, it's not at all obvious that this policy is going to work. So as August turns to September in 1973, things in Paris are becoming very grim. There's no bread. Inflation is going through the roof. Even Ross Pierre can't afford to buy his beloved silk stockings. So you know that things are getting very bad. And then on the 2nd of September comes completely devastating news. And this is news from Toulon, the great naval base on the south coast. And this is that the counter-revolutionaries surrendered the great port to the British of all people. So we talked about this in our series on Nelson and we saw it from the British perspective. But from the French perspective, the loss of this key naval base, traitors have betrayed it to the Royal Navy of all forces. It's completely devastating. And so unsurprisingly in Paris, there is a massive new wave of paranoia.
是的，确实如此。但这种征兵令被召集时的直接情况，这种政策是否会奏效一点也不明显。因此，随着1793年8月转入9月，巴黎的情况变得非常严峻。没有面包。通货膨胀飞涨。连罗伯斯庇尔都买不起他心爱的丝袜。所以你知道情况变得非常糟糕。然后在9月2日传来了完全毁灭性的消息。这是来自南海岸大海军基地土伦的消息。反革命分子将这个大港口投降给了英国人。我们在关于纳尔逊的系列节目中谈到了这一点，我们是从英国的角度来看待它的。但从法国的角度来看，这个关键海军基地的丧失，叛徒们把它出卖给了英国皇家海军，这完全是毁灭性的。因此，不出所料，巴黎掀起了一股巨大的新偏执浪潮。
And starving mobs take to the streets, the enraget, you talked about in the previous episode, the enraged. Oh, yeah, moustaches. People with their bristling moustaches, terrifying. And one of their particular leaders, who is a seasoned radical named Gaspar Schomet, he puts into words their motivation in a great public speech. Every day we learn of new trees and new crimes. Every day we discover the emergence of new plots. And these words carry massive weight with the Sonsculotte and the enragee,
饥饿的暴徒走上街头，就是你在上一集谈到的“狂人派”。哦，是的，胡子。留着竖起胡子的人，太可怕了。他们的一位特别领袖，一位经验丰富的激进分子加斯帕尔·肖梅特，在一次伟大的公开演讲中表达了他们的动机。我们每天都听到新的背叛和新的罪行。我们每天都发现新的阴谋出现。这些话在无套裤汉和狂人派中产生了巨大的影响，
because Schomet is not some nobody from the slums. He is effectively the chief. legal and administrative officer in the Paris Commune, which is basically the municipal government of the capital. And on the 5th of September, Schomet leads a march on the convention. So this is the day after he'd given that rabble-rousing speech. And a great crowd of mustachioed, Oraget, follow him, cheering, singing patriotic songs, waving slogas and banners, war on tyrants, war on aristocrats.
因为肖梅特不是贫民窟里的无名小卒。他实际上是巴黎公社的首席法律和行政官员，这基本上是首都的市政政府。9月5日，肖梅特领导了一场针对公会的游行。这是他在发表那次煽动性演讲的第二天。一大群留着胡子的“狂人派”跟随他，欢呼、唱着爱国歌曲，挥舞着口号和横幅，向暴君开战，向贵族开战。
That's all of that. And they arrive in the convention, and Schomet leads them on a kind of invasion of the convention. And inside, he delivers a petition on behalf of the demonstrators who are massed at his back. And then he gives a lengthy speech. And when he finishes this speech, upstands Barre and he gives that momentous slogan with which we began this episode. let terror be the order of the day. And Barreier goes on to say, let us be in revolution because everywhere counter-revolution is being woven by our enemies. The blade of the law should hover over all the guilty.
就是这些。他们到达了公会，肖梅特带领他们进行了一种对公会的入侵。在里面，他代表聚集在他身后的示威者递交了一份请愿书。然后他发表了长篇演讲。当他结束演讲时，巴雷尔站了起来，发表了我们本集开头提到的那个重大口号：让恐怖成为当天的秩序。巴雷尔接着说，让我们处于革命之中，因为到处都是我们的敌人编织的反革命。法律之刃应该悬在所有罪犯的头上。
Now, Rob Spierre, he is president of the convention at the time. He actually finds the invasion of the petitioners unsettling rather than inspiring. He's a stickler for propriety. He doesn't really approve of this action from the streets. but with his kind of customary acuity, he's very quick to take advantage of this proclamation that terror should be the order of the day. As we said, it doesn't become an official motion of the convention, but it's taken on board by the committee.
现在，罗伯斯庇尔当时是公会主席。他实际上发现请愿者的入侵令人不安，而不是鼓舞人心。他是一个循规蹈矩的人。他并不真正赞同这种来自街头的行动。但凭借他习惯性的敏锐，他很快利用了“恐怖应成为当天秩序”这一声明。正如我们所说，它没有成为公会的正式动议，但被委员会采纳了。
And isn't this just a brilliant example of the way in which, rather than necessarily the whole business being directed from the top, there are radical in in ines from the streets and part of the process of institutionalising the terror is actually saying, well, we don't want mobs roaming around the streets, lynching people and stuff. We want to centralise it, bureaucratize it, we want it done on a proper basis. And that's what Rob's free and the Committee of Public Safety are really all about. Yeah, they're saying, okay, you want terror and we agree the needs of the Republic demand it. Let's provide the legal instruments that will enable us to enforce it, rather than having mobs going around murdering people in prisons. That's basically it. That's their
这难道不是一个绝佳的例子吗？说明与其说整个事情是由高层指挥的，不如说街头有激进的冲动，而制度化恐怖的过程的一部分实际上是在说，好吧，我们不希望暴徒在街上游荡，私刑处死人什么的。我们想把它集中化、官僚化，我们希望它在适当的基础上进行。这就是罗伯斯庇尔和公共安全委员会真正关心的。是的，他们说，好吧，你们想要恐怖，我们也同意共和国的需求需要它。让我们提供能够使我们执行它的法律工具，而不是让暴徒在监狱里到处杀人。这基本上就是了。这就是他们的
kind of rationale. And I think, you know, one shouldn't be cynical about it. They think that this is for the best, I think. So what does this mean in practice? So on the 5th of September, they split up the Revolutionary Tribunal, which had been established a few months previously to try political prisoners. They split it into four concurrent chambers, which means that they can expedite the processing of cases. They decree that the judges and jurors who are trying these cases should be appointed by the committee themselves. So that means that they can vet who's going to be on these juries. And following this, unsurprisingly, the acquittal rate drops precipitously. So it increasingly becomes very unusual to be acquitted. And then on the 17th of September,
基本原理。我认为，你知道，人们不应该对此持愤世嫉俗的态度。我认为他们认为这是为了最好的结果。那么这在实践中意味着什么呢？因此，在9月5日，他们拆分了几个月前成立的旨在审判政治犯的革命法庭。他们将其拆分为四个并行法庭，这意味着他们可以加快案件的处理速度。他们下令，审理这些案件的法官和陪审员应由委员会亲自任命。这意味着他们可以审查谁将进入这些陪审团。随之而来的是，不出所料，无罪释放率急剧下降。因此，被无罪释放变得越来越不寻常。然后在9月17日，
the key development, the law of suspects, it's called. Very notorious process of legislation because it vastly broadens the category of person who is liable for arrest. So just to go through people who can now be arraigned under this law of suspects, nobles who had displayed a lack of patriotism and revolutionary zeal, emigre, so people who had fled abroad, and government employees who have been discharged from office. And so there are quite a few of those. Anyone who lacks a certificate of good citizenship, and this certificate was something that is issued by the revolutionary authorities to serve as an identity card.
关键的发展，所谓的“嫌疑人法”。非常臭名昭著的立法过程，因为它极大地扩大了可能被逮捕的人的范围。仅仅列举一下现在可以根据这部嫌疑人法被传讯的人：表现出缺乏爱国主义和革命热情的贵族、流亡者（即逃往国外的人）、被免职的政府雇员。所以有相当多这样的人。任何缺乏良好公民证书的人，这份证书是由革命当局签发的，用作身份证。
But inevitably, it has come to serve as well as a kind of an official stamp of ideological purity. If you don't have one, then you are, by definition, a counter-revolutionary. So you need one. Anyone who fails to demonstrate a satisfactory discharge of their civic duties, I mean, again, if you want to get rid of someone, you could apply that to almost anyone. And then most sweepingly of all, and I quote, those who, by their conduct, relations or language spoken or written, have shown themselves partisans of tyranny.
但不可避免地，它也成为了一种意识形态纯洁性的官方印章。如果你没有，那么你从定义上讲就是反革命。所以你需要一个。任何未能证明圆满履行公民职责的人，我的意思是，同样，如果你想除掉某人，你可以把这套用到几乎任何人身上。然后最全面的是，我引用，那些通过他们的行为、关系或口头或书面语言，表现出自己是暴政党徒的人。
So this is a sweeping, I mean, literally terrifying law. But of course, for true patriots, that's the point of it. That's what it's serving. And Tackett draws on the diaries of this woman, Rosalie Julien, who's the mother of one of Robespier's agents out in the provinces. And she thinks the law of suspects is. brilliant. She absolutely loves it. And she writes to one of her sons, it is so necessary for the security of the state that even those who are innocent victims cannot complain if they are truly
所以这是一部全面的，我的意思是，字面上令人恐惧的法律。但当然，对于真正的爱国者来说，这就是它的意义所在。这就是它的服务对象。塔克引用了罗伯斯庇尔在省里的一名特工的母亲罗莎莉·朱利安的日记。她认为嫌疑人法是天才的。她绝对喜欢它。她写信给她的一个儿子，它对国家安全是如此必要，以至于即使是那些无辜的受害者，如果他们是真正的
Republican. So in other words, you know, you get convicted, sent to the guillotine. You should, you shouldn't moan about it, but just reflect that you're serving the cause of the people. We've heard this so many times in history in similar circumstances. You know, if you're innocent, you have nothing to fear. So, and if you have something to fear, if you're frightened, well, you're that's just so you're guilty. Yeah. I mean, I think that reflects the mood of, you know, complete paranoia that is governing, not just the committee itself, not just the convention, but the streets of Paris,
共和党人，也不能抱怨。换句话说，你知道，你被定罪，被送上断头台。你不应该为此呻吟，而应该反思你是在为人民的事业服务。我们在历史上在类似情况下听过太多次了。你知道，如果你是无辜的，你就没什么可害怕的。所以，如果你有什么可害怕的，如果你感到害怕，好吧，那只是因为你有罪。是的。我的意思是，我认为这反映了不仅统治委员会本身，不仅统治公会，而且统治巴黎街头的完全偏执的情绪，
a sense that there are traitors and conspirators everywhere and that it's only by really violent repression that the revolution can be saved. And again, I mean, anyone who has seen the operations of social media today will kind of recognize a very pale echo of that mood, I think. When the mob moves, the mob moves. If you have been cancelled, it just shows that you were right to be cancelled in the first place. But you know what? The thing is, it works. Yeah. The revolution is saved. The terror serves the purpose for which it has been introduced. A key moment comes on the 6th of October when Leon, the second city of France. It's been under siege for two months. It's finally.
一种认为到处都是叛徒和阴谋家，只有通过真正暴力的镇压才能拯救革命的感觉。同样，我的意思是，任何看过今天社交媒体运作的人都会认出那种情绪的微弱回声，我想。当暴徒行动时，暴徒就会行动。如果你被取消了，这只是表明你一开始就应该被取消。但你知道吗？事实是，它奏效了。是的。革命被拯救了。恐怖服务于它被引入的目的。一个关键时刻出现在10月6日，法国第二大城市里昂。它被围困了两个月。它终于
finally falls. And the Committee of Public Safety decrees mass executions and the destruction of all the buildings in the city that are not owned by the people. And Robespierre, echoing a line in Tacitus, declares epigrammatically, Lyon is no more. And Couton, so the guy who had too much sex and got confined to a wheelchair as a result, and he's the committee's man on the scene. He wants to go even further and deport vast ways of the population, which he sees as kind of incorrigibly counter-revolutionary. And he writes to Robsbier and says, you know, they're so counter-revolutionary that I feel they will be for generations. So we need to bust them out and kind of settle them in the depths of a country.
终于陷落了。公共安全委员会下令进行大规模处决，并摧毁城中所有不属于人民的建筑物。罗伯斯庇尔呼应塔西佗的一句话，警句式地宣布，里昂不复存在。而库通，那个因为性生活过度而被限制在轮椅上的人，他是委员会在现场的人。他想走得更远，驱逐大量人口，他认为这些人是不可救药的反革命。他写信给罗伯斯庇尔说，你知道，他们是如此反革命，以至于我觉得他们世世代代都会这样。所以我们需要把他们赶出去，安置在国家的深处。
But Robsfier refuses this. He says that's too extreme. And he continues to insist that the mass of the people are naturally virtuous. They're naturally good. So even in Lyon, they can be trusted. But the people who cannot be trusted are the counter-revolutionaries who had brought Leon to such ruin. They have to be dealt with with extreme prejudice. And Robespierre knows precisely who ultimately are to blame.
但罗伯斯庇尔拒绝了这一点。他说这太极端了。他继续坚持认为广大人民天生是善良的。他们天生是好的。所以即使在里昂，他们也是可以信任的。但不能信任的是那些把里昂带入如此毁灭境地的反革命分子。他们必须被极其严厉地对待。罗伯斯庇尔确切地知道最终是谁该受指责。
Yes, so this brings us to the people that were beginning to be locked up in the last episode. And these are the people who were previously the dominant faction in the national. Convention, and these are the Gérondins. Now, if you were being more critical of Robespierre, you would say, these are people with whom he once broke bread. These are people who were once members of the same radical clubs as he was. They were part of the revolution. They were just as enthusiastic as he was.
是的，所以这把我们带到了上一集开始被关押的人。这些人是之前在国民公会中占主导地位的派系，即吉伦特派。现在，如果你对罗伯斯庇尔持更批判的态度，你会说，这些人是他曾经一起共事过的人。这些人曾经和他一样是同一个激进俱乐部的成员。他们是革命的一部分。他们和他一样热情。
But he doesn't see it that way, does he? And he has this long charge sheet that as he sees it leaves no room for doubt that they have actually been plotting to undermine France and its people from the very beginning. Yeah, and I think this charge sheet does matter to the sense of Robs-Pierre as someone who's personally virtuous, because even though he has broken bread with a lot of the Girondin, he has also been pursuing a venomous personal feud with the leader of the Girondin, Brissot, the anti-slavery campaigner, who's often seen as their leader. And so it is important to Robs-Pierre that he lays out the charge sheet so that people won't
但他不这么看，不是吗？他有一份长长的指控清单，在他看来，这毫无疑问地表明他们从一开始就一直在密谋破坏法国及其人民。是的，我认为这份指控清单对罗伯斯庇尔作为一个个人品德高尚的人的感觉很重要，因为尽管他与许多吉伦特派共事过，但他也一直在与吉伦特派的领袖布里索（反奴隶制运动者，通常被视为他们的领袖）进行激烈的个人恩怨。因此，对罗伯斯庇尔来说，列出指控清单很重要，这样人们就不会
say, you know, he's just engaged in a faction battle. So the charge sheet is that they had foisted this disastrous war on France. It was a Girondin who had pushed France into declaring war on Prussia and Austria, and then in the form of General de Murgier had tried to betray it. So the evidence there to Rospier seems clear. The treason is arrant. He charges them with being soft on nobles, soft on priests, and that their laxness had served to foster the rebellion in the von derange.
说，你知道，他只是参与了一场派系斗争。所以指控清单是他们把这场灾难性的战争强加给了法国。正是吉伦特派推动法国向普鲁士和奥地利宣战，然后以迪穆里埃将军的形式试图背叛它。所以那里的证据对罗伯斯庇尔来说似乎很清楚。叛国罪是显而易见的。他指控他们对贵族软弱，对牧师软弱，他们的松懈助长了旺代的叛乱。
He then charges that following their expulsion from the convention in June 1793, which we talked about in the previous episode, their crimes had become even more palpable. That those who had escaped house arrest, and among these was Jean-Marie Roland, husband of Madame Roland, the Salonista, former minister of the Interior under Louis XVIth, that they had all fanned out into the provinces and that these were the traitors who had fomented the counter-revolutionary. movements in Lyon, in Marseille, in Con, in Bordeaux, that these were the traitors who had handed Toulon over to the Royal Navy. And that therefore only one punishment could possibly suffice for this abominable behaviour. And Rosbier is determined to see it enforced. And I think that even though Robsbier does have this kind of personal feud with Brissot and some of the other Girondin, He genuinely does not see himself as governed by selfish emotions. He genuinely sees himself as Cicero foiling the conspiracy of Catiline.
然后他指控说，在1793年6月他们被逐出公会之后（我们在上一集谈到过），他们的罪行变得更加明显。那些逃脱软禁的人，其中包括让-马里·罗兰（路易十六时期前内政部长、沙龙女主人罗兰夫人的丈夫），他们都散布到各省，这些人就是煽动里昂、马赛、卡昂、波尔多反革命运动的叛徒，这些人就是把土伦交给英国皇家海军的叛徒。因此，对于这种令人憎恶的行为，只有一种惩罚可能足够。罗伯斯庇尔决心看到它被执行。我认为，尽管罗伯斯庇尔确实与布里索和其他一些吉伦特派有这种个人恩怨，但他确实不认为自己是被自私的情绪所支配。他确实认为自己是挫败喀提林阴谋的西塞罗。
He sees himself as the disinterested defender of the people of the revolution of France. And the measure of this, I think, is that enormous numbers of people agree with him. Yeah. They agree with his self-estimation. And people in the committee, people in the convention. Yeah, they do. They completely. And they back him. And so because of this, he is able to nail the Gérondin as the people who have to be punished for all the disasters that are overwhelming France. And so those Gierondin leaders who are still at liberty are declared outlaws. And when they're caught, they are guillotined. And some of them commit suicide. And so there's a kind of terrible story of two prominent Giron Dian. who commits suicide out in the countryside in a field, and their bodies are found a week later, half devoured by wolves.
他认为自己是人民、革命、法国的无私捍卫者。我认为衡量这一点的是，大量的人同意他的看法。是的。他们同意他的自我评价。委员会里的人，公会里的人。是的，他们确实。他们完全同意。他们支持他。因此，正因为如此，他能够将吉伦特派定性为必须为压垮法国的所有灾难负责的人。因此，那些仍然自由的吉伦特派领袖被宣布为亡命之徒。当他们被抓住时，他们被送上断头台。他们中的一些人自杀了。所以有一个关于两名杰出吉伦特派的可怕故事，他们在乡下的田野里自杀，一周后他们的尸体被发现，被狼吃了一半。
Meanwhile, in Paris, the trial opens on the 24th of October of Bristow and 20 other Girondins. And initially from Ros Pierre's point of view, their trial does not go well. So the accused, unsurprisingly, are very defiant, they're very eloquent. They sound convincingly patriotic, because, of course, they are patriotic. And actually, it goes so badly for Robespierre that five days into the trial, someone in the committee stands up and proposes that the trial be abandoned, that it's clearly not justified or required. But Robespierre is having none of this and he steps up to the tribunal and he makes a really striking and I think sinister counterproposal, namely that the jury should be asked, and I quote, whether they have enough evidence to satisfy their conscience. And this is massively to move the goalposts because basically what that means is that jurors are being asked to arrive at their verdict based not on evidence that might have satisfied a traditional court of law. But rather on their own intuition, their own gut feeling, their sense of whether the people who are being prosecuted are guilty or not.
与此同时，在巴黎，10月24日对布里索和其他20名吉伦特派的审判开始了。起初，从罗伯斯庇尔的角度来看，他们的审判进行得并不顺利。所以被告，不出所料，非常挑衅，他们非常雄辩。他们听起来令人信服地爱国，因为当然，他们是爱国的。实际上，这对罗伯斯庇尔来说进行得非常糟糕，以至于审判进行了五天后，委员会里有人站起来提议放弃审判，说这显然是不合理或不需要的。但罗伯斯庇尔对此不予理会，他走到法庭前，提出了一个非常引人注目且我认为阴险的反建议，即应该问陪审团，我引用，他们是否有足够的证据来满足他们的良心。这极大地改变了目标，因为基本上这意味着陪审员被要求根据不是可能满足传统法庭的证据，而是根据他们自己的直觉、他们自己的直觉、他们对被起诉的人是否有罪的感觉来做出裁决。
And that's adequate. And this idea that you start a trial, it doesn't go well. So you then change the rules halfway through to rig it so that it will go as you want. We will see this again in this series, actually. It's a disturbing development. And yes, at the same time, Rob Speer is always anxious to give it the pattern of legality, isn't he? I mean, I genuinely think he feels it's the right thing to do. If you're a revolutionary, he was right to do it, I think, is,
这就足够了。这种你开始一场审判，进行得不顺利，然后你在中途改变规则来操纵它，以便它按你想要的方式进行的想法。我们实际上会在这个系列中再次看到这一点。这是一个令人不安的发展。是的，与此同时，罗伯斯庇尔总是急于给它披上合法性的外衣，不是吗？我的意思是，我真诚地认为他觉得这是正确的事情。如果你是一个革命者，他认为这样做是正确的，是
his feeling and the feeling of his supporters. So unsurprisingly, in the wake of all this, the Girondin accused are found guilty and the verdict is brought in on the 31st of October. And one of the 21 Girondin who've been found guilty, the moment the verdict is announced, he reaches for a knife that he had smuggled into the trial and he stabs himself and kills himself. And his corpse is still loaded onto the tumbril, together with the 20s, Girondin who have neglected to commit suicide in this way. And on the way to the guillotine, the surviving 20 Girondin all sing the Marseillaise. And it's, you know, if you're a Girondat, it's a very stirring scene, but doesn't help them. They will lose their heads.
他的感觉和他支持者的感觉。因此，不出所料，在这一切之后，吉伦特派被告被判有罪，判决于10月31日宣布。在21名被判有罪的吉伦特派中，判决宣布的那一刻，其中一人伸手去拿他偷带进审判现场的一把刀，刺向自己并自杀了。他的尸体仍然被装上囚车，连同其他20名没有以这种方式自杀的吉伦特派一起。在去断头台的路上，幸存的20名吉伦特派都在唱《马赛曲》。而且，你知道，如果你是一个吉伦特派，这是一个非常动人的场景，但对他们没有帮助。他们将失去他们的头颅。
And then soon afterwards, on the 8th of November, they are followed by the most famous female Girondin. And this, of course, is the wife of Roland. Madame Roland. And she is very much a living reminder of happier times when her salon had been the most fashionable, the most influential in the whole of revolutionary Paris, the great meeting place for the Giron d'Ath throughout 1791 and 1792, but not just the Giron-Dand, because Robsfier himself had attended it. And indeed, Madame Roland had praised Robespierre two years before her execution for ranking among the small number of courageous men who are always faithful. to their purpose. Rosbier, of course, would say that he's still being faithful to his purpose. The irony. Madame Roland, however, does not, because when she's brought to the guillotine, she gazes across the square and she sees this great plinth on which there had previously stood a statue of Louis XIV. And that, of course, has been toppled and in its place has been erected
然后不久之后，在11月8日，他们之后是吉伦特派中最著名的女性。这当然是罗兰的妻子，罗兰夫人。她确实是一个活生生的提醒，提醒人们更快乐的时光，当时她的沙龙是整个革命巴黎最时尚、最有影响力的，是1791年和1792年整个吉伦特派的伟大聚会场所，但不仅仅是吉伦特派，因为罗伯斯庇尔本人也参加过。事实上，罗兰夫人在她被处决前两年曾称赞罗伯斯庇尔跻身于少数始终忠于其目标的勇敢者之列。罗伯斯庇尔当然会说他仍然忠于他的目标。讽刺的是。然而，罗兰夫人并没有，因为当她被带到断头台时，她凝视着广场，看到了这个巨大的基座，上面曾经矗立着路易十四的雕像。那当然已经被推倒了，取而代之的是竖立起
as a clay statue portraying liberty. And Madame Roland gazes at this and then utters very famous word. It's liberty, what crimes are committed in your name. And a few days later, news of his wife's death is brought to Roland, and he leaves the place where he's been hiding out, and he goes out into the countryside, and he sits beneath a tree on a country lane, he draws out his swordstick, and he impales himself. That is the end of him. Yeah. But Dominic, Madame Roland, although her fate is famous, her life.
一座描绘自由的粘土雕像。罗兰夫人凝视着它，然后说出了非常著名的话。自由啊，多少罪恶假汝之名以行。几天后，她丈夫死亡的消息传到了罗兰那里，他离开了躲藏的地方，走到乡下，坐在乡间小路上的一棵树下，拔出他的剑杖，刺向自己。这就是他的结局。是的。但多米尼克，罗兰夫人，虽然她的命运很出名，但她的生活。
last words, are very famous. She's not the most famous woman, nor even perhaps the most tragic, to have perished in that autumn of 1793, because a month earlier, a woman whom Madame Roland had always hated and despised had gone to the guillotine ahead of her. And this was a woman who, for patriots, everywhere, had come to seem the embodiment of everything that they were pledged to destroy. And that woman was, of course, Mary Antoinette. Crikey. So in our next episode, we will be tracing how the revolutionaries seek to complete the final eradication of the last relics of monarchy. They'll destroy the symbols of monarchy. They will take Mary Antoinette herself to the guillotine. And we'll be talking about one of the most affecting stories of the
临终遗言，非常出名。她不是1793年那个秋天死去的女性中最出名的，甚至可能也不是最悲惨的，因为一个月前，一个罗兰夫人一直憎恨和鄙视的女人在她之前就上了断头台。这是一个对于各地的爱国者来说，已经成为他们誓言要摧毁的一切的化身。那个女人当然就是玛丽·安托瓦内特。天哪。所以在我们的下一集中，我们将追踪革命者如何寻求完成对君主制最后残余的最终根除。他们将摧毁君主制的象征。他们将把玛丽·安托瓦内特本人带到断头台。我们将谈论最令人感伤的故事之一
entire revolution. This is the fate of Marantir and its son. So he's the boy, little boy, who royalists regard as Louis the 17th, and his fate is a very, very sad story. So don't miss it. Now, that's not the only episode we'll be doing. We're doing the fault of Danton. We'll be doing the attack on Christianity, and we'll be doing the final showdown, the climax of the reign of terror, the fall of Maximilliers, Krobesbyr. And if you want to hear all those episodes now, and you're a Restis History club member, you can. So your next, you know, three or four hours are going to be brilliant. If you are gutted because you're going to miss out, fear not.
整个革命。这就是玛丽·安托瓦内特儿子的命运。所以他是那个小男孩，保皇党人认为他是路易十七，他的命运是一个非常非常悲伤的故事。所以不要错过。现在，那不是我们将要做的唯一一集。我们将做丹东的倒台。我们将做对基督教的攻击，我们将做最后的摊牌，恐怖统治的高潮，马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔的倒台。如果你现在想听所有这些剧集，而且你是“历史俱乐部”的成员，你可以。所以你的接下来的三四个小时将会非常精彩。如果你因为错过而感到难过，不要害怕。
You can go to therestestis History.com. You can sign up. You can join the club immediately. You'll get those episodes right away. But also, you can look forward to a whole load of supplementary benefits, the kind of thing that would make a Republican or Royalist weep with envy. and you could also sign up, if you like, to our newsletter, which will have loads of loads of stuff about the French Revolution,
你可以去therestishistory.com。你可以注册。你可以立即加入俱乐部。你会立刻得到那些剧集。但你也可以期待大量的补充福利，那种会让共和党人或保皇党人嫉妒得流泪的东西。你也可以注册，如果你愿意的话，订阅我们的时事通讯，里面会有大量关于法国大革命的内容，
more than you could possibly want to read. Surely not Dominic. Surely people want to read every last word of it. It's that good. Yeah, that's actually true because it is really good. So there's loads of French Revolution content. Next up, Mariantoinette, do not miss that episode. It is an absolute banger.
多到你可能读不完。肯定不是这样，多米尼克。肯定人们想读完它的每一个字。它太棒了。是的，那确实是真的，因为它真的很好。所以有大量的法国大革命内容。接下来，玛丽·安托瓦内特，不要错过那一集。它绝对是一部杰作。
Tom, on that note, merci, and au-voir. A-vovoire. with 350 passengers The great game Strategic struggle between Britain and Russia We assess a Prime Minister With high confidence it was Russian Holding the Russians accountable is World War III
汤姆，说到这里，谢谢，再见。再见。载有350名乘客。大博弈。英国和俄罗斯之间的战略斗争。我们评估一位首相。高度确信是俄罗斯。让俄罗斯人负责就是第三次世界大战。
They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people Man in the Kremlin is playing Alex Got to ask yourself You want to play Or not You're the Prime Minister You've done nothing! We would need to understand the policy context.
他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。克里姆林宫的人在玩弄亚历克斯。你得问问自己。你想玩吗？还是不玩？你是首相。你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。
All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today, disseminated into an operation order, or Fraggo. A Fraggo that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. New from Goulhanger. Who is going to be able to pull this off? You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuff, Duffie. An audio drama journey like no other.
所有相关的背景今天都将构建为一个框架，分发到作战命令或Fraggo中。一个说要杀死俄罗斯总统的Fraggo。是的。Goulhanger的新作。谁能做到这一点？你是我的士兵，对吧？汤姆·麦克达夫中士，达菲。一段独一无二的音频戏剧之旅。
Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technically rigorous, geopolitical action thriller. We have two-tides-friendly key-a-e. Where Britain plays its strongest hand. He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Bear Hunt. Available now, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。被设计为一部技术严谨的地缘政治动作惊悚片。我们有两潮友好的关键。英国发挥其最强手牌的地方。他是最棒的。对抗其最强的敌人。猎熊。现已推出，无论你在哪里获取播客。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。